black lives matter has issued a
statement they are standing by jesse
smallett even though he has been found
guilty
and you know
it's a really important story for
regular people because everybody knows
at this point that justice millet staged
the whole thing it was a hoax he was
trying to make more money he exploited
black lives matter and the protest
movement to advance his career and now
you can see
official statements from the black lives
matter organization that they don't care
they're standing by him saying we don't
care police are liars he's done too much
for us
that's important for regular people so
you can explain to them look it's not
about justice it's about political power
and here's proof now we got an even
weirder story the new york city mayor
has said they refused to surrender to
black lives matter and warned hawk
newsome not to burn the city down it's
interesting we're starting to see some
pushback to black lives matter and
antifa in california 11 antifa members
have been arrested and charged with some
very serious crimes for beating regular
people apparently there was a trump
rally antifa shows up and started
beating kids like teenagers
pretty aggressive stuff and then where
does this lead us to well the intrepid
journalist andy noe who has been
documenting this much to the chagrin of
antifa is now being sued by people
because he retweeted them this is
anti-full law fair they're mad about it
so they're literally swinging him i i'll
say this right now before we get the
show started andy no mark my words
there's a lot of political play here but
i will say this on the merits andy will
win a summary judgment the judge will
laugh this this case out of court and
then andy will seek legal fees and
likely win i'll just say he will win i
will make a hard prediction on this you
can come back and if i'm wrong i will
accept being wrong but i am so positive
that this is a stupidest lawsuit ever
filed andy will win on summary judgment
he will never see a trial the judge is
going to be like this is ridiculous
for the you know case for the defendant
and then andy's going to say legal fees
is it granted laughably bad and we'll
get in all this stuff we also got uh
inflation hitting across the country and
it's a little bit in the weeds but i
think this one's big we can definitely
talk about how it's screwing over the
working class and i have this article
from the intercept that really pissed me
off
inflation is good for you it's bad for
the one percent they eat they lie so
easily to manipulate poor people into
destroying themselves and supporting
this trash so we'll get into it joining
us today is of course libby emins from
the post millennial hi how's it going
hey you're the editor-in-chief right i
am i'm the editor-in-chief at the post
millennial
sweet and you work with andy i work with
andy he actually just sent me a message
oh yeah he wanted me to show you
something oh what is it
is it is it the part from a lawsuit yeah
uh
it's his last tweet about being an
effective journalist means that people
will try to silence you yeah and he's
fundraising for his legal defense so if
you want to check that out oh definitely
libertycenter.org slash retweet
so
i used one of his articles today from
newsweek
yeah it's funny they're like he's not a
journalist and i'm like pretty sure
newsweek isn't a far-right publication
and it's not an opinion piece it's a
straight news piece they're so salty
because very few people are willing to
actually report on what they're doing
and stand up to it well and andy is is
reporting on crime he doesn't do opinion
pieces i recently was like andy we we
were talking about something i was like
that's a great idea we should do an
opinion piece on that and he was like
meh i don't want
you know he does he does straight news
stories and uh they come after him
because he's good at his job you know
that stupid daily beast story about uh
about this lawsuit and they're talking
about and they use they're like oh andy
has had all of these dcma strikes
against him and it's like yeah that's
not evidence of anything other than
people are out to get him right you know
that's what that's about it's a yeah
it's it's because they just don't like
uh they don't want to be they're violent
crimes to be reported on i really want
to i want to talk so much about that one
but i felt like we couldn't lead with it
because it's a little esoteric but we'll
get into that when we'll build up to it
with the black lives matter riot stuff
we got luke chilling yeah libby's from
new york city so i'm very excited to
find out how my former homestead is
turning into a hellscape it's going to
be a great conversation exciting and the
shirt that i have now i think becomes
more popular by the day and it reads
people will forget your words people
will forget your accomplishments but no
one will forget that you voted for joe
biden
and it's a great one because it catches
a lot of people off guard and you could
get yours and be a part of street
activism by just going to
thebestpoliticoshirts.com and because
you do i'm here thanks for having me
what's up everybody ian crossland here
ready to rock and roll good to see you
ian crossland.net check it out
and i am also here pushing buttons on
this very calm friday night we're gonna
have a lot of fun love having libby here
love my ladies so let's get into thanks
before we get started my friends go to
timcast.com become a member because that
is the lifeblood of our operation as a
member you get access to exclusive
members only segments from the tim
castaire podcast as well as our green
room show which is behind the scenes
when people are showing up and hanging
out and we got a new show pop culture
crisis talking about pop culture
but it's from our perspective freedom
you know independent values things like
that so it's definitely something you
want to check out and most importantly
as a member it funds our journalists
that's it what i'm hoping to do is just
get more and more writers on more and
more subjects tackle these issues to
fact check them and do a better and
better job far from perfect but better
than what you're going to get from the
mainstream media and that's that's the
intention everything we're doing is when
you guys sign up we can allocate those
funds straight to hiring more
journalists and we just hired another
journalist michael robison he's got
monkeys it's really cool right look at
my instagram at tim cast and we were
just uh hanging out we got to meet one
of the monkeys so really cool stuff and
he writes fantastic articles so again
don't forget to support our work smash
the like button right now subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's get started with this one
we were initially going to start with
jesse but i think this is actually more
important context as we get into black
lives matter from the daily mail quote
we are not going to surrender to black
lives matter new york city mayor elect
eric adams warns blm leader hawk newsom
not to quote burn down the big apple and
refuses to back down on reinstating
plainclothes nypd units
it's kind of crazy when we're at a point
where a the mayor of you know the
biggest city in the country is warning
a group of leftist activists not to burn
the city down isn't it isn't it
shouldn't there be a little bit more
than that like hey you threatened to
burn the city down like that's a
terroristic threat you guys literally
did smash windows and destroy things a
year ago
maybe those threats are not idle threats
and there should be some legal
ramifications you know maybe a slap on
the wrist maybe they at least need to
come out and be like don't threaten to
burn it all down but how many times do
they say this stuff
yeah you know they say it a lot blm says
this a lot and hawk news newsome also is
much further to the left i think even
than the national blm
groups and he's spoken out against the
national blm groups he's one of the ones
who was uh bringing suit against them
for
having fundraised all that money and
like nobody saw any of that money except
you know patrice culler's got a bunch of
new houses or something that's nice yeah
that's really nice wow well it was for
her family it was for sure she's doing
very well for herself yeah i mean
every family needs a nice little house
in tapanga canyon a couple of them you
know that's just one a few you know half
a couple like half a million dollar
houses yeah but yeah so the thing about
newsom is um he's very vigilant about
that i talked actually talked with him
after the um there was like a whole
incident uptown with some tourists who
were in town and they didn't want to
show their vax cards or something like
that and they ended up getting kicked
out of car mines and then when i talked
to him about it he was like actually the
hostess was racist and used racist
language and this whole thing um but
yeah he's very vigilant against the
plainclothes cops and i want the
plainclothes cops back on the street
pulling them off the street has been a
disaster that's how
the police know what's going on in the
community you know they're there on the
street they're involved the the context
is that uh when they defunded the police
in new york they got rid of the
anti-crime unit that's right and then
crimes sky rocketed murders mugging
who's getting killed like black kids are
getting killed that's what's happening
black people are getting murdered so you
know people were shocked the the super
lefties that i know were shocked when
eric adams won the democratic primary
which essentially meant that he was
going to be mayor which he is going to
be
they all wanted maya wiley and these far
left progressives but the black
communities the conservative communities
the latino communities all wanted adams
and it's pretty clear why they wanted
him you know he was a he's from the city
he was a d.a
um he was a cop yeah and he was he's
definitely going to crack down on crime
in these neighborhoods and save black
lives like that's what he's going to do
i'm i'm i'm i'm glad to hear it you know
maybe i don't agree with this guy i'm
not a fan of what the democrats have
become but if people are expressing
their support for a cop
as much as i can say you know there's a
lot of things that i don't like about
the nypd the cpd regular people saying
you know what we hate more we hate you
burning down our our businesses and
throwing rocks through our windows right
this is a pie in the face to the
extremists woke left but when they did
break when those when they did bust down
businesses when they did steal from
private enterprises you saw the police
department stand back and kind of watch
everything happen you saw some of the
high command of the nypd literally
literally get on their knees with the
mayor saying we support you guys as of
course they were causing massive
chaos massive pain for the average
citizen so you know the previous
administration acquiesced
totally to blm they wrote their name in
front of trump's
tower and arrested anyone who dared to
express another political opinion across
that particular street so to to see this
kind of transition it's not even a major
transition it's just the guy saying hey
we're not going to have any bloodshed
we're not going to have any rioting here
i mean that should be a normal statement
it's nothing out of the ordinary and
shouldn't be
yeah i mean de blasio also did not think
that new yorkers cared about their own
quality of life and i've talked to
members of city council about this you
know who said that there are members of
city council who don't think that their
constituents care about quality of life
and anyone who lives in new york there
isn't anything else that is literally
the only thing there is there's really
expensive everything and not getting
trash in your face and stabbed when you
walk down the street so that's the
important thing and if adams can bring
some of that back
that's a good thing but i still you know
i don't i don't agree with any of the
vax mandate stuff he's come out on in
favor of that we now have a new mask
mandate in the entire state because of
the stupid idiot garbage no one elected
her governor
you know
the next person's always worse right
right it's always worse that's what i'm
thinking too it's like if we get rid of
biden we have kamala and she is just
even the worst of the worst worse
she's terrible
yeah and this whole thing with the
masking now you like businesses are
going to be able to decide if you have
to wear a mask or if you have to show
your vaccine card or
whatever let me i want to address what
luke was saying about the police because
i think there is an interesting kind of
double-edged sword here i'm not a big
fan of what the police were doing
letting people suffer but my i guess my
point is more like regular people when
they say they want eric adams they are
saying no to black lives matter and
antifa extremists and we needed people
to stand up and say something to that
now it is i think an issue
when you have a police department and
you have the whole city and this that
you know the the core democrat movement
being like abolish or defund the police
well it's no surprise that when the cops
are like we don't have the resources to
deal with this so we're not going to
deal with it you can't expect me to go
out and then put my life on the line
when you will not stand up and defend us
as well right you had in new york i
think i think it was in new york the
police came out and said we are being
slammed in the media for all of these
crimes when there were 375 million
police interactions and only i think it
was like nine unarmed black men being
killed or like 13 or whatever yeah so
they're the media is just
draw like drumming up all of this hate
for cops when
99.99 of cops are just like routine
stops right
most of them but you know they also they
also they also did shut down you know
private businesses in staten island that
were going against the lockdowns uh the
nypd is it's one of the most funded
police departments i think in the entire
world i believe their budget correct me
if i'm wrong i think you would know this
more than i would uh libby their budget
was six billion dollars now it's five
billion is that correct they did pull a
bill a billion yeah but it wasn't the
nypd shutting down restaurants in staten
island it was the sheriff's that was the
state that was under cuomo's
jurisdiction yes but it's still police
officers that came in it was but it was
not the nypd okay because the nypd if
you were walking around going to you
know basically were speakeasies during
the pandemic
uh the nypd did not come bother you at
all they brought in state troopers it
was yeah that was what was going on in
staten island that was not nypd that's
corruption
but that's it's it's the the these these
cops that are basically like uh attila's
gym in new jersey the local cops showed
up and the cops said something like
you're all you're in violation of you
know public ordinance that being said
have a nice day folks and they all
clapped and cheered right so what did
the city do they called outside
departments to come in and the outside
cops with a smile on their face were
like i don't know you i don't care about
you screw off
callousness that that to me is like
you know what man these cops may be from
out of the community but
people need a way to like call them out
shun them for violating human rights the
the decree of an executive does not give
police the authority to do these things
no i mean people have to stand up for
their own values and that's it turns out
that's one of the hardest things for
anybody to do
is to
have a value system make their decisions
based on that value system and to uphold
it with their with their
this is their lives every day you know
this is why i'm like you know during the
whole george floyd riots and stuff i was
kind of like in many circumstances if
the cops aren't going to defend people
who want to abolish the police i mean
good this is what people have asked for
in the cops giving it to him that being
said when then when you then get police
going to small businesses and putting
the jack boot down i'm like you want me
to defend you now not gonna happen as an
institution well in a lot of it's not
the police that are going around
you know enforcing these restrictions
it's individuals and business owners who
are enforcing the restrictions for the
most part new york especially yeah and
and that's sort of the that's sort of
the worst case scenario i think if it
was police coming in we could all be
like no police don't do that but it's
individuals standing against other
individuals it's citizens taking up the
enforcement it's citizen middle managers
well the the difference i think is in
like new york it's most mostly the
individual restaurant owners are the
enforcers of these mandates that's right
but there still are many circumstances
in which police were engaging in this
behavior until this gym as i mentioned
the woman who was trying to sell things
on facebook live in north jersey so we
we've seen several instances of this
and
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna come out and
defend uh you know organizations that
take the good will when when we defend
the police and say defunding them is
insane if anything they need better
training better funding better programs
and then what happens they say screw the
little guy we don't care we're told to
do it so we'll do it granted as you
mentioned a lot of nypd were just like
nope right i've heard stories from
people in new york where they were like
people have you know tried calling the
cops over vac you know people are free
to leave with masks and the cops just
laugh yeah they're like what do you want
me to do about it dude
they're like
we're not coming out for this it's
ridiculous yeah i mean my experience uh
recently in new york city uh tell me if
you're wrong maybe this was just
particularly in the neighborhood that i
was in no one's enforcing anything uh as
far as mask mandates i haven't seen any
kind of enforcement of that in local
businesses and private businesses vax
mandates no one asked me about my papers
no one asked me to put on a mask those
are the experiences that i just had a
few days ago um are you seeing the same
kind of
just not caring about any of this kind
of bureaucracy made up decrees there's a
lot of people that don't care
um there's a lot of like i went to a
diner the other day
and it was like i'm not to say where it
was because i don't want them to get in
trouble there was no issue
the vax mandates now have extended to
children so children are supposed to now
show their vaccine cards and a lot of
places are not going to enforce that
either also the mask mandate that came
down from uh kathy hulkel today um is
like
businesses get to decide so you can
enforce it yourself which also kind of
means like businesses that are doing
badly are they really going to stand
there and be like put on your mask or
you can't come in you know i wouldn't
i'd be like come on in please buy some
stuff um but there's been a lot of
places that are not asking for
vaccine paperwork or anything else
because they want people to come in and
also they don't care there's also though
a ton of people more than i've seen in a
long time walking around outside with
masks on
in their cars by themselves with masks
watching cnn too much right and there's
uh the subway people are like fully
masked on the subway it'll be like i'll
be on the subway and i'll see somebody
and we'll be like oh what's up nice i
want to pull up this story without a
mask on we have the story from star
tribune and this is despicable albert
lee restaurant owner found guilty of
violating state coveted mandate a jury
of three women and three men took only
an hour of deliberation to convict lisa
hansen she was sentenced to where do we
have the sentencing down here it's uh
there we go
she was sentenced to 90 days in jail
which began immediately and a 1 000 fine
considerably
considerably
more than what albert lee city attorney
kelly don martinez who prosecuted the
case had sought meaning the prosecutor
didn't even wanted to go that crazy and
the judge was like nah lock her up three
months why because she opened her wine
and beer bar flouting tim waltz's
executive order to shut down last winter
during the cove 19 pandemic and was
found guilty of six criminal misdemeanor
counts thursday by a free-born county
jury
it was it was cops who came and arrested
her for this this is minnesota this is
minnesota she fled to iowa and then
sheriff deputies came and arrested her
so these are people these are officers
look you got to understand in places
like new york city as much as you might
be saying like well the nypd weren't the
ones going out and doing this the the
leadership are appointed by democrats
they do not believe in the same moral
systems moral frameworks and values that
we here do just because we might be like
there are good cops out there and
they'll be smurching the name of
officers over you know a few fringe
cases you need to realize that in places
like seattle there are auntie for cops
right there
yeah i mean there was an antifa person
running for the uh basically like
attorney general of the city
um in seattle and then you know she lost
but uh she was
entrenched you know she was running for
that it's interesting too i was talking
to some friends about this the other day
there's a
there's definitely a difference today
between um the way that republicans and
democrats conservatives liberals
whatever terminology you want to use
approach things it used to be that
everyone basically seemed to have the
same goal
and the question was how do we get there
what is the process
i don't think there's
the same goal in mind at all and i don't
think that
there's even a similarity of world view
at this point yeah i i think for the
most part everyone's become increasingly
selfish
and like the judge in this case or the
prosecutors they're just basically like
i'm gonna get mine yeah i don't care i
mean we're seeing what's happening all
around the world and it should be a
warning shot to the rest of the world
especially with what's happening in
germany in australia in austria and
italy in france where we're seeing just
you know elderly women walking by
big police officers grabbing their hands
demanding to see their papers demanding
to see their identification and throwing
them in jail giving them huge fines
stealing their hard-earned money
punishing them scaring the crap out of
them because they didn't comply with the
whims of the state i think what's
happening around the world in some of
these places is what a lot of
politicians want to happen here in the
united states and i think because of
people fighting against it because of
people not complying because of the
state of florida and other people saying
hey i believe in my human rights i have
dignity i have a life here that i will
fight for and i will protect no matter
what i think that's one of the only
reasons why
society totally hasn't gone the way as
many other societies have gone to where
even protesting even just simply
complaining
is banned or made illegal and and it's
absolutely crazy to see that happen in
australia to see that happen all over
europe where you can't even protest
that's crazy we have that here with
corporations corporations ban protest
in the u.s how so well you have twitter
you have social media platforms well
they've been using speech they ban
speech and speeches protest yeah and
they also and they also banned people
from organizing and from having groups
and doing events together covering the
elaine maxwell trial yeah that's another
big one
[Laughter]
it's obvious what they're doing they're
like it's bad enough we had to pull this
stupid campaign with maxwell anyway the
last thing we wanted someone to be
tweeting about it right yeah or just no
talking talking about the justice system
oh you know or just you're saying it's
terrible or just how the government took
your tax dollars for over 30 years and
ran an international extortion child
trafficking operation that's another big
one you know okay
that's that's something that people
that's i mean i'll give you something oh
i got a whole bunch
look i think you know we've seen a lot
of the details out of the epstein stuff
and now we're kind of getting off the
rails from where we just were it's like
you know these small town cops arresting
this woman and then epstein and an
internet no but i will say there's a
simpler there's a simpler thing it's
like
you've got how much how much of our
money without our consent goes to
literally bombing civilians right and
and and for some nebulous cause where
they tell us what are they saying they
were saying on tv about ukraine we we
fight over there so we don't gotta fight
here and i'm like you think russia's
gonna invade
let alone hawaii and then just a really
quick point before i i'm going to leave
it off to you i think it is
interconnected because there was police
officers in new york city in florida
that knew exactly what was going on they
had the victims they had children that
were coming to them and they were told
to shut up by their superiors and they
had to shut up and there was no justice
for thousands of victims and thousands
of children that came forward so sorry
go ahead
wow yeah yeah you didn't know about this
libby
no i don't know all about okay okay oh
the abstain stuff is good yeah the
absolute stuff is out yeah i mean i've
read about the upstate yeah there's a
number of police officers that fell into
depression there's a number of police
officers that were silenced shunned and
couldn't do their job because the higher
up said shut up obey our orders and they
did and they had to
that's what goes on with a lot of things
yeah you know that's pretty clear yeah
and it happens in some of the most
atrocious atrocities that we can't even
mention or talk about and and that to me
is frustrating to understand people
still putting a lot of their faith in a
lot of their power and a lot of their
hope which i think is is is needless
into this kind of system that they're
going to be doing the right thing i
think we should be more skeptical than
just hopeful from my perspective you
know when i think about cops defunding
police and police as an organization i
think like the trash people pick up the
trash and you're like okay if there's an
organization of trashment across the
united states and a small group of them
started dumping trash on lawns and they
were like f this we hate these and
they're like targeting black people you
know some racist trash men you wouldn't
say like defund trash people no no more
trash pickups you totally need the
garbage collector
so like right how do you deal with or i
mean just firefighters and police
imagine a video of a firefighter at a
fire and he like he's got the hose and a
little old lady walks by he just sprays
her and she gets knocked over and
they're like time to shut down the fire
department
it's over fire
how do you hold them accountable you
criticize every time they do something
wrong you try to hold them accountable
and if they don't if they're not held
accountable they shouldn't have any
institutional power or money until they
can be accountable and until they can be
trustworthy until they can be honest and
real with the people that they're
serving because they're supposed to be
serving the people not doing the bidding
of the special interests that many times
they just take the orders blindly and do
whatever they want there was a there was
a big thing during occupy wall street
where nypd were working uh in uniform as
private security for wealthy individuals
who want to go to restaurants in the
financial district right that makes
sense
so so you come out as a protester and
you see police officers in uniform
badges and everything and then you
realize they were hired as private
security
for the wealthy elites of new york city
yeah there's a lot of cops that
moonlight as security but in uniform
with their badges i don't think they're
supposed to do that well there's an
official program within the nypd where
corporations could hire police officers
to show up at their businesses many
banks use police officers and hire them
i don't know if this program still
exists but i know it did exist a few
years ago and they were able to hire pay
pay their salaries and they would show
up particularly protect uh their
business and essentially just stand
around there because that was a
deterrent for a lot of criminals seeing
oh there's a police officer here i won't
come and steal from this place oops
sorry though trashing the joints dude
their job is to protect people but then
but their real job is to do what their
supervisor tells them to do or they're
going to lose the job yeah so like
that's a big conflict of interest right
off the bat including up to some of the
worst atrocities i mean isn't that true
of soldiers isn't that true with the
military any of these kind of
enforcement organizations are all about
making sure that the people are
following the orders like you can't have
a bunch of people it just wouldn't work
if everyone was out there
making their own assumptions about how
the law works you know there has to be a
coordinate effort coordinated effort in
order for it to be successful and right
now it's running through people like um
authoritarian individuals so maybe in
the future we'll the system will be
altered so that
we'll be able to police without having
authority telling people what to do i
don't think that that's really how it
works
i think there always has to be authority
to tell people
if you're going to have a if you're
going to have some sort of army
people have to follow the orders in the
army
i'm not policing though policing i mean
in new york city like that's that's an
army
to a certain extent how many is like 30
something thousand it's a lot it's a lot
of people and the thing too that
happened in new york is that a bunch of
low-level crimes basically got
decriminalized and stopped being
prosecuted
so that just opened the door for
criminals to do bigger crimes you know
and the way that these smaller crimes
worked i was actually listening to a
podcast about this with ines
yeah and has this podcast um
but essentially the idea is that those
low-level crimes um are not that
are now decriminalized the idea was not
that those low-level crimes are there to
be prosecuted and send people to prison
it's so that police have an intervention
point an early intervention point right
so if you're standing there on the
street corner smoking a joint
uh then the police can be like hey
what's up you're standing here on the
street corner smoking a joint that's an
intervention point right uh if turn
style jumping right hey you just jump
the turnstiles that's an intervention
point what other you know what else is
going on right and when you have a bunch
of crimes right and then people plead
down once they're in the court system so
then you have like this person went up
for a drug offense for you know five
years
did they really go up just for the drug
offense like they pled down a whole
bunch of other charges and landed with
one and took a sentence it's sort of
interesting i hadn't thought of it in
those terms um but it makes sense when
you start thinking about it in that in
that way let's talk about some wins we
got the story from newsweek by
journalist andy no
prosecutors make first move to break up
anti facel as 11 activists charged with
charged with violence now this is not an
opinion piece this is a factual news
report by uh by andy no for newsweek and
the reason i'm emphasizing a factual
news report by journalist andy no is
because
anti-fun these extremists have tried
their hardest to smear and besmirch his
name simply for reporting on what they
do this is it
newsweek is not some far-right
publication or some conspiracy blog
music is actually fairly left-leaning
and here we have a factual news piece
you see prosecutors are actually going
after antifa they said uh andy writes
this week the san diego county district
attorney's office charged 11 alleged
antifa members with felony conspiracy
and felony assault charges among other
crimes in a riot case where supporters
of former president donald trump and
random bystanders were beaten in the
pacific beach uh in pacific beach
california in january eight suspects
were arraigned this week they have all
pleaded not guilty
there's there's videos of what happened
there there are reports that there were
miners who are simply walking down the
street and ante decided to attack and
pepper spray them there was a guy who
was apparently long boarding with his
dog and they pepper spray this guy
for no reason because they assume if
you're there you must be a trump
supporter oh hey
i'm i'm curious here you know
i think we should be happy that finally
we're seeing law enforcement go after
antifa right
this is finally how long has it taken
but my concern is is it too little too
late and is it just kind of a show some
appeasement do you know what i mean are
they actually going to get serious
across the board around the country and
deal with this extremism well i want to
know exactly what happened in this
particular case before kind of exposing
an opinion on it but what brings me
to think about you know when when i hear
about this story was just a few months
ago when antifa was caught celebrating
because their opponents were being
arrested uh they were celebrating when
the fbi was going after trump supporters
and my first comment on them celebrating
it it's only a matter of time until the
state turns against you and starts
arresting you so i think this could be
the first of that i still want to i
still don't know a lot of the details
around this case but
do they have any charges against these
individuals no conspiracy and felony
assault yep oh okay among other crimes
yeah dude do they know uh let's see if i
can come down they come
yeah okay so we have
you know samuel ogden charged with
felony conspiracy and assault we've got
jesse cannon uh felony conspiracy felony
assault so you know basically they're
all being charged similarly and it's for
trying to cause uh a great bodily harm
to individuals they're fundraising to
try and and try and deal with this these
people thought they were untouchable
they felt like that the cops couldn't do
anything and you know what for several
years that was the case right
well the cops weren't doing anything for
for a long time and as we know the the
cops and the feds have a lot of data
they're they're running huge dragnet uh
information operations where they
literally are flying drones over a lot
of these protests they know a lot more
than they let on so i would say that you
know the federal authorities the
surveillance grids know almost
everything so to see this kind of turn
when they were previously cheered on by
many establishment institutions for
doing these actions to see them now face
the ramifications of them shows a kind
of very interesting turn i mean
there could be just not enough right
wingers for them to go after for the
petty crimes so they're like okay we got
to do something now and now they might
be going quick yeah we got to do
something to justify these overly huge
budgets that we got uh but um it's gonna
be i may not i need to read more into
this i wonder if this is actually
because the midterms are coming up and
the establishment democrats know that
this is a huge problem
i do think also though the courts have
proven to be the front lines lately and
it's been pretty fascinating to watch
justice at work you had um you know the
charlottesville stuff came up and those
white supremacist groups or whatever
were fined like
so much money enough money to completely
bankrupt them out of existence which is
kind of you know but they don't look the
and you had written house that was
proper justice this is all that trial
the shots are very interesting suing
private citizens who have no money just
doesn't do anything no i mean that's not
effective right i mean it's not going to
be effective for that but it is you know
an interesting thing to see that the
courts are really on the front lines of
this if you look at the most
um if the biggest stories that we've had
lately they've all been trials it's all
been like waiting for a verdict you know
yeah that's been that's been pretty wild
you know the supreme court oral
arguments have been heating up the whole
situation with the abortion laws
courts are the front lines they're the
it's interesting too because once things
hit the courts
you know
that's really where
that's really where you're going to
start to see what's going to happen like
what the precedent is going to be what
the law is going to be next year in june
the uh it's widely believed that the
supreme court is going to overturn roe v
wade yeah and that was leftist activist
there was one guy from i think from
slate and he was like that's it it's
done the supreme court will overturn roe
v wade and everyone started freaking out
he's like no no it's a prediction not a
statement of fact but it's probably true
and uh even like nbc was saying this now
i say this in the context of antifa
what will how the far left will be able
to rally a lot of crazy young people
around this should it happen
but that will be bad for democrats right
it will be bad for democrats the other
thing that's bad for democrats is that
they had to base abortion rights on a
supreme court decision and they could
never actually pass it on a federal
level it's a states rights issue it's
not elucidated in the constitution when
you heard the oral arguments i guess it
was whenever it was last week
and justice thomas who is so interesting
whenever he talks it's so interesting
because he was you know he hardly ever
says anything um but he consistently was
asking what is the basis
in the constitution for abortion rights
is it liberty is it this and you know
she's the uh the woman um i forgot her
name yeah council just kept being like
well she said that's abortion abortion
right yeah yeah the 14th amendment and
it's a liberty issue right
and i don't think that's i don't think
that's good enough and i think that it's
i think it's bad law because why is it
bad law because it's not actually a law
like they don't make a law it needs to
go through congress if they want a
federal abortion rights thing they need
to make an amendment and do it and they
can't and that's what kavanaugh said yes
he said why is this going to the court
not through legislation that's exactly
right here's what i see happening i
think antifa will definitely use that
this kind of stuff should they actually
overturn roe v wade they're gonna have a
powerful media asset to rally a bunch of
young ignorant people and people who are
not all with it if you know what i mean
into getting violent right because their
agenda is burn it to the ground and then
rebuild but the establishment democrat
their agenda is like when the moderates
over in the midterms
you've got a flailing economy you've got
a abysmal uh job growth you've got the
democrats trying to claim that joe
biden's we're in the biden boom period
you can only lie so much when people
can't buy serial anymore and you're
going to add to that the extremist
crackpots going around smashing up
windows and they know it so
i wonder if this is preemptive because
they're like if we don't start arresting
these people they're gonna go nuts and
it's gonna be it's not gonna be a red
suit a red wave a red tsunami it is
going to be a red great flood build your
arc now
i'm looking into this and these are not
federal charges it looks like this was
charges from the san diego county
district attorney san diego is has a lot
of right wingers in there so it wouldn't
surprise me if this was like a local
effort to them for them to go after
individuals that target other people and
hurt them because they worked with other
local police departments and it looks
like they have a very solid case here
as they also were able to get a whole
bunch of weapons drugs um on some of the
suspects that were arrested here i think
it was eight suspects in total there
were search warrants issued so this
seems more like a local issue rather
than a federal issue um so um i don't
you know i think that also matters
that's fine yeah why should it not be
local no i'm not i'm not saying it
matters i'm just saying that it is a
local issue it's not a federal issue
yeah so but where california leads the
rest of the country follows and i'm
really optimistic that this precedent
will kind of set the stage for some
other cities to do the same thing
do you think it will i hope so did you
know that um
uh i learned this from uh the redheaded
libertarian josie good friend of the
show that communists aren't considered
people for the for the sake of human
rights in the 1964 civil rights act so
this is really interesting actually
because i uh it's fallen out of i
suppose legal precedent but apparently
in the 1964 civil rights act it says
this provision will not be construed as
to provide you know
like rights to communists or people or
communist associated organizations or
something like that
antifa is quite literally rooted in
weimar germany's communist
anti-fascist action or whatever which
was literally a communist organization
they use the same flag same name so i
wonder if there is anything there we
should be worried about or i don't know
i certainly don't like the idea of the
government being like we've deemed you a
communist therefore because they could
call anybody a communist they could
claim anywhere else right
but
literally a communist organization and
you know maybe the reason we won't
actually see anything from that
provision is because we don't care about
it culturally and because many of the
people in federal law enforcement i know
this is state level charges but many
high ranking you know democrats are also
you know at the very least socialists
have communist leanings or are unwilling
to go after communists out of fear
yeah
i think they are afraid i think they're
afraid to go after you know i mean we
see this at the post-millennial all the
time right like these antifa people are
coming after us they come after andy all
of the time um and they have this weird
you know this communist ideology and
they don't they don't really care about
anything else and they just use the fear
tactics you know they say like don't
fund this business don't put your ads on
this business don't talk to this person
because i'm telling you to so trust me
and nobody ever looks into their
background or looks into like you know
the horrible things that they've done or
what they're about it's it's about time
you know people started waking up to
what these extremists do they lie they
cheat they steal and it's all for power
and a good example as we mentioned
earlier that they're still backing jesse
smallett even after he's been found
guilty yeah but let's talk about law
fair because i am really excited to talk
about this story
from the daily dot two journalists sue
andy know over his online use of their
videos they say no reposted their videos
without permission leading to online and
physical attacks from his audience i i
would just like to point out i do not
believe going to a court and suing for
damages and then being like people were
were or threatening us online is any
grounds for any complaint against andy
no because he had nothing to do with
that that's that's
immaterial they say two journalists have
filed a lawsuit against andy no for
copyright infringement journalists grace
morgan and melissa claudio lewis say
that no downloaded and tweeted their
videos without permission their suit
seeks damages and a permanent injunction
prohibiting no from posting their videos
without express consent now before i
show you this i would like i would like
to make one definitive statement and
prediction right now in the absolute
i welcome being wrong but
i will say it
andy no
will win on summary judgment
he will then seek legal fees
and he will win legal fees
this
lawsuit is so laughably bad
that i cannot believe they even wasted
one red cent to file it
what andy knows being accused of doing
is so beyond fair use i have to imagine
the first thing that judge is going to
say to the the plaintiffs in this case
says
are you sure about this you're going to
be billed by a lawyer for it and then he
might come after you you know andy could
file
a claim for legal fees and he will be
awarded them this is beyond frivolous
now there are lawsuits where it's like
now that's questionable at best okay so
good friend of mine cassandra fairbanks
she filed a lawsuit against some
reporter because she claimed the okay
hand sign was a white supremacy gesture
and cassandra lost because it is very
difficult to win these kinds of lawsuits
but let me show you here from the daily
dot
here are the tweets from melissa claudio
lewis she was on the ground filming she
said cops are getting guardian angels to
protect them here's one where said
maltco tried to bust out but found their
gate wasn't functional they say when and
when no andy no posted it he wrote
police observed the writing auntie from
antifa from behind a gate in downtown
portland last night and as you can see
andy no did not in fact download this
video all he did was used twitter's
internal function to repost it in a
tweet and thus you can see the woman's
name melissa claudio lewis and her video
hosted on her twitter account in andy
knows tweet in another tweet they say he
similarly altered text altering text is
here's the funny thing i just got it
if they're actually trying to make the
case like but but andy is being suited
because he also altered the text i'm
like that's in defense of andy altering
text for commentary or criticism is
transformative and it's commentary and
criticism exactly here's the best part
in the uh in the next tweet they
highlight you can see that andy no is
literally reposting their video directly
through twitter's tweet function he did
not download this video and re-upload it
you can see them in grace morgan's name
in this so let me make this very simple
andy no
retweeted people on twitter taking
publicly available videos providing his
own commentary on them for a newsworthy
purpose that's correct it is it is it is
like so laughably fair use yes that he
is going to win summary judgment that
means there will be no trial the judge
is going to read it and be like
dismissed
and it's not like they turned off the
retweet function or turned off comments
or anything like that it's just mad that
it was
that they just don't like andy and it's
because andy exposes them you know he
exposes them so thoroughly um yeah and i
think that he is so correct to be
fundraising for his defense on this one
so definitely so is this a copyright
complaint or a harassment complaint is
it right copyright but he attribute he
put their name yeah
attribution attributions are relevant
yeah um i would like to reference the
notorious case of akilah hughes v carl
benjamin
carl benjamin aka sargon of akkad on
youtube uploaded raw clips from akilah
hughes's youtube and the only thing he
did he there's nothing in the videos
it's literally her raw clips from a
longer video and he titled it liberal
something like liberal sense of
self-awareness right she sued him
sargon carl very smart he kept his mouth
shut and everyone asked him and he says
look i'm in a lawsuit i can't speak
about it right akilo went on twitter
talked her mouth off gave press comments
here's what i'm doing i'm going to
assume and i'm going to take everything
the judge in that case was like are you
sure you want to go forward with this
because this is very clear-cut fair use
right and aquila was like he's
infringing on my copyright he didn't
provide commentary or criticism she had
to change lawyers and carlos kept his
mouth shut carl won on summary judgment
he filed for legal fees and he won again
if andy no
downloaded their videos reposted them
and then wrote lol
that would be fair use commentary and he
would win yes that's that's it yeah so
what andy noah has done here is he
didn't even download them he just used
twitter's public functions to retweet it
and all he did also was say you know and
what happens is antifa posts it and says
look at these horrible police and andy
posted and says actually there's another
way to look at this situation maybe take
a look at it from this perspective
can't handle it you know and
there's more than one way to look at
anything this is a this is like a
lawsuit about messaging
yeah so
morgan told the daily dot that they're
hoping to make it harder for andy noe to
steal journalists content and change the
narrative of their reporting something
he has built his career off of if you
post newsworthy video to twitter where
it can be seen by the public
someone can retweet you
that's something you've you you've
acquiesced to now i will say i will say
for those that are wondering
how do news wires work one of the core
the core questions of fair use is if you
are infringing upon their market
now this is important
if i post a video
on twitter there is literally no defense
i mean you can try and muster up one but
they're gonna be like look you posted
the video to twitter it's publicly
available can be shared and embedded i
don't know what you want us to do
but if i post maybe like 20 seconds and
then i say to license the full video go
to my website and someone goes to my
website takes the full version and
reposts it and says well i saw part of
it on twitter now you're actually
infringing upon my market that's
different so
pub publishing something
makes it now available to the public it
can be transformed it can be commented
on to be fair
you it it quite literally is copyright
infringement but there is an exception
to you know whether a judge will allow
this and it's quite quite clear what
this is actually
is i think it's called ad terrorim
that's what they were the judge called
it in the achilles case these antifa uh
journalists
are suing andy no not because they think
they'll win they're trying to drain his
resources and force them into a fight
now and they want to force him off
twitter i mean it's so clear that they
just want to force him off twitter right
they don't want him to be able to do any
reporting on them and without andy i
mean andy was at the forefront of this
kind of reporting
um they tried beating him they tried
him it didn't work yes
it didn't work but
an important question here libby maybe
you would know this was he crossing
state lines was he tweeting
because you know that could be another
reason to to go after him the mainstream
media is really
sorry the corporate media really doesn't
like that yeah they really don't like
when you uh leave your home either so i
don't know oh yeah they're against that
this what's amazing is they're claiming
that andy no
violated cop dmcas
lewis says if i had violated dmca's that
many times my account would no longer
exist why andy gets a permanent pass i
can only guess it's because he's
retweeting you and twitter allows it and
when you complain they take some of the
videos down
that's it
well looks it doesn't look like a
retweet is that actually a retweet yes
so slightly different it's slightly
different what andy did was he took the
direct link to the video and this is a
core function of twitter you can if
someone posts media you can take their
link from their twitter and put it in a
tweet and then write whatever you want
but you can see it's included her name
in it yeah this video is not being
hosted by andynow's account and it's
directly attributed right right and you
click the one's name and it shows you
their account where they've posted it
and you can see what she said about it
it is literally a retweet of her content
so does this function remove the other
person's commentary yes oh okay this
this is when this this is you retweeting
the link to their media gotcha as
opposed to retweeting the entirety of
their tweet so i say retweet because
there's no real other word to describe
what this is someone posts a video with
their name on it it produces a link on
twitter that you can then paste in your
tweet which is hosted by their account
not yours so you're basically embedding
their
video in your tweet right right i don't
even retweet i i don't think embed is
the right word
this video is is i i guess technically
it's the case but it's quite literally
taking their tweet their media and
putting it in it might be different
tweeter has uh twitter has an option
when you uh
let's call them tweeter from now on i
think that's more appropriate when you
when you press on a video it gives you
the option to share it through multiple
platforms or tweet the video a part of
your own tweet attributing the person
who created the video it's it's it's
functionally retweeting yeah you can
embed if you go to publish.twitter.com
that lets you actually embed a tweet in
another tweet but that looks well that's
called quoting so like like luke said
you can just click the video and be like
share this video in a tweet so andy no
isn't downloading or stealing anything
it's like here's a public video let me
comment on it well and they're like
he's really careful about that you know
he wants to attribute he wants to and
that's part of it too i mean he wants to
show who the people are who are out
there making these videos and doing
these actions he doesn't want to hide
that he doesn't want to take credit for
anybody else's work
so it's a twitter feature right did he
not retweet and just type a paragraph
above their their twitter because this
format looks better
i don't know why he did this i know he
just literally clicked on the video and
clicked tweet video it's a better way to
do that because
so like right now i have a video up ian
right and i just pressed on it all right
and it came up and it's and i have an
option here i tweet video and then it
has the video here and i just get to
write the commentary underneath it nice
this segment should be called teaching
ian
i also want to stress uh as it pertains
to copyright law you may disagree with
this but i can literally download this
woman's video
upload it to my own twitter account and
put h
here's a video from jesse kelly
from andrew pollock on twitter it's the
exact same format jessie kelly should
andrew pollock say jessie kelly probably
not no you shouldn't it's clearly
frivolous and you can see how they've
how they've they've framed this in the
article from the daily dot they're like
i'm getting harassed i'm getting threats
because andy is posting my videos what
they don't like
is that when they publish this
information they want to control the
narrative they want to frame it as
negatively as possible for the police
and for the city and andy now can take
the video provide his own commentary and
that's quite literally look
to say it's fair use it would be like
imagine there is a 20 foot tall giant
with a big shirt that says fair use
incarnate that's what it is
there's no question like the judge is
going to be like i'm confused this is
fair use and they're going to be like
but i'm getting harassed and he's going
to be like i don't understand
what are you talking about right also
online harassment who doesn't get online
harassed doesn't every doesn't that
yeah the definition has changed the
definition of harassment has definitely
changed when we would do terms of
service at mines it's like what it's not
the same as like harassment from the 80s
that was when someone was like banging
on your window and yeah it's totally
different this is like you wake up and
somebody's like
you know i hope you get killed i woke up
to this the other day actually andy was
was like uh libby they're saying nasty
things about you now that's like oh good
what's new thanks that's great
you know and this is why
i think you know this is why it's
important to support independent
journalism it's why it's important to
support journalists like andy or outlets
like the post-millennial because these
people are coming after us they're not
coming after us for any reasonable
reason we're not doing anything wrong
they just don't like that we're actually
reporting on their criminal activities
they don't want to be called out they
don't want anyone to
look at their activities from the
perspective of you know you guys are
committing crimes
you are hurting other people actually
physically hurting other people and now
you're whining that somebody's saying
something nasty about you on twitter
you're out there injuring others let me
i'll i'll say this too there are a bunch
of uh accounts
and that go into the members only
section of teamcast.com and post those
videos
and that is where they're
arguably not in fair use territory and
the reason is although they're providing
commentary or criticism on our videos
there's
this was where it gets a little bit
murky
by publishing stuff that we have behind
a paywall it's arguably infringing upon
our market by giving away our content
for free however personally i'm still
fine with it right like when i see the
leftists and they're like tim paul and
his members only said extra while i'm
like oh you know look it's commentary
it's newsworthy i don't like they're
giving us away for free but it's kind of
a preview yeah so i'm not i'm not going
to be bothered with dealing with it and
i honestly welcome the commentary and
criticism
it's tough because i don't want that i
mean you like you buy a book and then
you quote the book or a movie comes out
and you show a clip from it you talk
about it fair use i think that's fine
you know the thing is though if you if
there's like a movie and you take a clip
from it on youtube they'll probably just
knock you down anyway even though it is
fair use and you gotta fight for it yeah
i played a small like even a second from
the matrix uh trailer and automatically
copyright strike like why it's not a
strike from the trailer
uh yeah a flag from the trailer yeah
from the trailer but aren't they isn't
that out there in order and it wasn't
even it wasn't even the trailer it was
just a few seconds as i was just like
having it in the background going
through the browser
i'm like okay wow yeah that happened to
me with uh with joe rogan actually
because i pulled up his youtube video
and was talking about the podcast
without playing it and it automatically
got flagged wow and i had to be like joe
you know it's not like can you get it
off and he was like oh sorry man but it
was automatic i've had happen to me too
where people are like i've had um angry
leftists be like tim poole copyright
claimed my video and i'm like no i
didn't like youtube automatically does
it dude and so then i've gone in and
released it be like i don't want it i
don't care
whatever the hell you want
that's that's the thing right one of the
problems that the the whatever the
freedom faction i guess the libertarian
little l has is that we're willing to be
like well they're allowed to use our
content to criticize us and then they
will they will sue you right so it's
it's it's look man
the sad reality is that uh cheaters win
yeah cheaters cheaters win not always
most of them get caught eventually
that's not true
you think they get caught because some
get caught but you'd be surprised how
many people are playing shady games look
everybody lies on the resume
really really i was actually encouraged
to i said i'm being hyperbolic okay wait
are you serious i think people don't lie
in their resume as an actor when i went
to la they were like okay this is the
way it works in la you're not in the
union you're not sag but if you want to
be sad put sex put your sag on your
resume and then when they see it they'll
think you're already in the union
they'll hire you and then when they
realize you're not in the union they'll
just put you in the union and that's
what they did wow they hired me for a
commercial and then they just were like
well all right just give him this union
card that's wild yeah most people lie on
their resumes fake it till you make it
that's like a fairly common thing i
never lied on like a jo other like a
non-acting resume but i was encouraged
to by my agent and it worked it was
crazy i'm actually a really poor liar
i'm just i'm just bad at it i felt
really weird antifa has a penchant for
lying they're really good like there's
that video where jack bosobi got punched
yeah and the cops literally watch it and
the woman goes i didn't see anything i
didn't see anything it's like lady the
cops witnessed it shut your mouth yeah
but they just they just lie i mean she
wasn't a good liar to be honest but hey
justin smellette
that dude that's intense lying yeah i
think you should get an oscar wow
too i should get an oscar for we should
just like simone biles
athlete of the year even though she like
pulled out of all the competitions but
you know how they do uh like the academy
award uh like actors will make a pitch
video to like try like this if they do
writing like you have like like the the
actors will make like a video
campaigning to win oh i don't know yeah
yeah like to win an emmy or something we
should make an emmy oscar campaign for
jesse smallette oh my goodness this is a
really good idea yeah and you know what
he could use our support
we'll have like slow motion scenes and
it'll be like for your consideration
jesse smallette and then it shows him
crying
he's like i fought back
i fought back we gotta use some of the
jim cramer saying that economy is doing
great better than ever
don lemon singing the praises of biden
saying cass is down five seconds i'm
writing this down the first thing we
need
we need our own awards right and chris
cuomo saying that he treats stories
about his brother the same as anything
yeah
the top
we also need like a top globalist award
who's gonna get the most uh most uh and
it's always schwa it's always klaus
no no it's always just he won an emmy
who wasn't the one in emmy was that
injured
for your consideration he had to give it
back the fake always emmys they had a
huge book deal too it's crazy
and chris cuomo's chris cuomo's book
deal is scrapped too andrew cuomo just
like single-handedly ruined that entire
family the whole dynasty really you know
i mean i guess he did get the tappan zee
bridge renamed after his dad
yeah but i mean it really should just be
the tappan zee bridge what's it called
now the mario cuomo bridge oh gross the
tappan zee bridge is classic it's in
really rosy you know i can tap it across
the tappan you know the sphinx in egypt
that was by one of the pharaoh's kids
apparently
it took it used to be a lion a giant
lion statue and he he carved the face
had the face of it carved out to be his
father's face and they hated it so much
that he disfigured this beautiful lion
statue that they destroyed the nose is
that what happened and that's kind of
the story is that's what i've read bro i
was watching story i was watching joe
rogan oh there was a guy who said that
there used to be water there
there was like water damage on the
sphinx like an east to west river like
the largest river on earth ran east to
west across the sahara oh that's crazy
that's what ocean is sam and they said
that means the sphinx is older than we
realized yes
that was a crazy episode that was so
cool when humans and lions and now we're
totally derailed we're talking a little
bit we're talking
assange we're talking about julian
assange
yes
renaming the bridge after his father and
then how they the egyptians were so
angry that he did that they defaced it i
think i think um i'm i did write this
down i think we should put together a
fake news emmys yeah so we should have
like jim cramer saying the economy is
doing well
uh you know joe biden saying no mandates
you know that kind of thing jesse
smallett crying on tv
i think jesse's gonna take it man cause
you gotta let's be real all right
we offer a prize we offer a prize reward
and he'll definitely have to do it
i will quite literally put a get a big
thousand dollar check let's do it and
literally offer it to them and give them
like a give them a giant one like i'm
happy that's right and they stand
holding up the fake news emmy award and
take a picture with it and they they
will get a check for a thousand bucks
they just for themselves or to the
charity of their choice to them they can
literally i will literally give a
thousand bucks as a prize for winning
but they got to take a picture holding
up the big check saying fake news emmys
right and then we'll do a video and
we'll celebrate it
they won't accept the money nobody would
i think that's really funny but look
politics aside we all need to recognize
jesse smallett is one of the greatest
actors of this or any generation
dr fauci uh i think is in the
consideration as well for the huge lies
that he's been telling the crazy thing
about smollett too is like he went out
there
and he lied in order to elevate his
status as a victim yeah you know to
claim that and and in order to like show
how white supremacists the the american
society is and he hired two black eyes
amazing to beat him up and then he
claimed that those black guys were
homophobic even though one of them he
was like fooling around with or whatever
yeah it's like really your first of all
that's how you treat your friends
that's how you treat someone that you're
like
really into apparently like come on
that's what happens in hollywood and
then everyone's still standing by him
and it's like really because smollett
would not stand by you he's through he
throws his boys under the bus yeah
honestly yeah yeah he can lie
he's great yeah
in fact people are backing him still
well because he's talented still backing
him i i have to imagine that right now
in hollywood they're like man i can't
believe jesse did that but the boy can't
act he can't
have he has a film out like some b-boy
yeah or he was like working on it he was
writing a screenplay during this whole
period of time they couldn't get any
work oh wow no i i mean this sincerely i
mean you got to do something you know i
mean at least be productive but i do
mean this sincerely i really do think
justice milette is talented yeah i i
genuinely believe that you know when he
went on tv and he kept a straight face
and the way he lied and the way he
played everybody
the dude really can act and you got to
understand that a lot of these actors
when they're on movie sets they have you
know cut try again cut try again hey try
it like this for jesse to be sitting on
the hot seat on gma and go through that
interview and nail the crying and
everything i genuinely like this this
guy yeah he's got some theater
experience he definitely is good at what
he does he's just a scumbag
he's a great sociopath
you know to a certain extent he wrote a
great script like this should be the
script this is the story nobody cares
what he thinks about anything else like
this is the story and he could play
himself yeah absolutely or he should
play one of the ocean yeah
that would be better yeah everybody else
hillary clinton should also be in the
running she just came out and started
crying
after talking after reciting her uh oh
like
her speech if she would have won the
presidency how do you do that like if
that were me and she's selling that and
i had so publicly been humiliated like
that i would never first of all i would
never go back and read the speech but i
would never publicly be like
my goodness to go out there and and show
everybody no no she's now shilling of
course where she's charging people money
but everyone's still backing her we
should also how much clinton was on the
epstein plane
i would have trouble just like facing
society i would be like and i'm over
here in
yeah we're going to have a tea
when we do the uh when we do the hillary
clinton for your consideration for the
fake news emmys we can do one of two
things one where she's like i'm now
going to read you my speech where i have
to won the presidency and then she like
briefly turns into a lizard
puts eye drops in gigantic lizard eyes
and then changes back and goes
or or she could be a robot and she's
sitting there going engage crying
sequence and then water just sprays out
of her eyes violently like anime
characters
it was watching her
cry i'll do air quotes here i was just
like wow does she think that like
i wonder if she actually can cry i
wonder if she's like hardcore sociopath
and she can't lie absolutely
from my own personal perspective and
opinion i mean what else do you need to
know about a career politician that
literally has celebrated the brutal
torture and death of muammar gaddafi uh
she literally what did she say she was
like we came we saw he died
[Laughter]
and the videos of what happened to
gaddafi were absolutely horrific
when i was a kid i lived in uh i lived
in hanover massachusetts and for the
fourth of july one year i think i was in
like fourth or fifth grade there was a
bonfire with an effigy of muammar
gaddafi burned at the stake and everyone
cheered and i was like yay hillary also
people used to make fun of me like all
the kids would make fun of me they'd be
like oh libby is gaddafi your uncle
oh my god you are literally the
stupidest people in all the suburbs it's
amazing hillary clinton seems to me like
the kind of person where like she's
smoking a cigarette and she'll like walk
past like a little kid and then just
like
put the cigarette out on the kid's head
and flick it
she's definitely the kind of person to
just pop your balloon just because she
can't yeah 100 percent accidentally
jostle your ice cream yeah a little bit
well like you you remember that story
that that that um former i think it was
an air force guy or was i see a secret
service guy wrote a book yeah and he
said that he there was a there was like
they're on a plane and there were air
force like officers who were on this
plane transporting hillary and she holds
up her empty wine glass and goes
oh my god and then like these guys are
like yo i am like an officer in the air
force i'm not here to pour you one and
she just kept going
like wow cough drop
yes are you coughing ma'am yeah if you'd
like to get up and grab your own drink
you might as well uh maybe that'll clear
your throat
get it yourself
yeah there's a lot of that's like i say
to my kid you know he'll be like mom
can i have some more juice and i'll be
like yeah you know right where that is
that's right over there
there's cups and everything you even
know where those are my parents would be
like i don't know can you
go and i feel like uh like are you
asking for permission because if you
want it you can go and do it yourself
yeah it's like
there's so many stories of these like
snobby elitists treating people
absolutely horribly i remember talking
to one of those can we just pause for a
second
the snobby elitists are treating people
badly yeah yeah who would have thought
how could that be but i remember
i remember
yeah
i have a hunch uh just a little bit
there but i remember even talking to one
of the staff members that was
helping out the bilderberg group and
they were serving the bilderberg members
and they were told specifically don't
look them in the eye don't start
conversations don't talk to them look
down and make sure that all their needs
are served whenever they uh might even
have a need or we might think they might
have a need yeah so like on faulty
towers don't talk about the war yeah and
and they literally can't even look
people in the eyes as they're serving
them and they're supposed to look down
the whole time and it's just utterly
ridiculous there's it's kind of weird
with that kind of elitism now because
you'll go places and the staff is all
masked up
and yeah you don't have to and nancy
pelosi doesn't have to she's she's very
happy but she's someone
marjorie taylor green like a whole ton
of money for not masking and she doesn't
do it herself someone pointed out that
in uh the hunger games that there was a
like the the capital city had servants
who had their tongues cut out had to
wear masks or something i forgot what
they were called you guys remember that
um i forget but they did they just had
their tongues cut out they didn't have
to wear a mask oh okay uh something no
i'm pretty sure there was there was an
image of them like wearing masks
yeah i don't know people comment and
chat can can can get us on that one but
is it any surprise to you that this is
what humans do you know what i mean
avoid eye contact because when you make
eye contact with someone you're stealing
their energy and you're changing the way
their brain works so these but there's
just people don't want to be tainted
there's no joy in treating people badly
you know for so many people there is
there's it's like i i found this too you
know
during the pandemic but even before like
if i'm gonna go into a place if i'm
going to i don't know buy something from
person or order something
we're both experiencing this moment of
life together like let's just have it
not suck you know let me acknowledge you
you can acknowledge me we're here
together
there's no issue i was in a restaurant
on my birthday i took my son out for
like seafood feast basically for my
birthday which is my favorite thing and
the waitress and this was down the shore
in jersey uh we were like hi you know
how's it going you know whatever order
our food and at the end of the meal she
was like i just want to thank you guys
for being so nice and we were like uh
what do you mean and she was saying that
people come in there they don't look at
her they're gruff they just complain at
her they tip her poorly like all of the
mean things and i was like but
you're here at this restaurant you you
just brought me a meal that is so nice
you know that's so wonderful that i
could come here and order a meal and you
would bring it to me that's great i'm so
grateful for that it's amazing
what a thing when i got to eat i'm a bit
of a comedy and i always tip ridiculous
ridiculously high amounts sure but i
figured out a way to exploit luke's and
cap
i'm like lib left when i'm tipping i'm
like i'm going to give this waiter 100
tip and then i'm like now how do i
convince luke who's lib right so i make
it a competition yeah and i'm like well
look i'm gonna get the better service
luke can you handle it it looks like
i'll tip better and then luke ends up
tipping i'm pretty sure i started the
last competition you started the first
one the first one the first one was
pretty hardcore uh and i was like all
right we could play but but at the end
of the day you know it's it's all in a
good service since the people actually
serving us do get you know a lot of
support check it out i got this story
here from timcast.com inflation soars to
nearly 40 year high
um i just wanna i want you guys to
understand the consumer price index rose
6.8
in november that means
from november of last year till this
november if you did not get at least a
seven percent raise a six point percent
raise then you are losing money so i
would like to stress people will forget
your words people will forget your
accomplishments but people will never
forget you voted for joe biden because
this is part of the reason why we have
this don't shout out to the best
political shirts.com but i genuinely
mean it i mean a lot of people who voted
for joe biden this is what you get
now i think we all know that inflation
has been really really bad we don't need
like the latest metric to make us
understand this what i really want to
get at as we're ragging on the snobby
elites is this article which
this one a flame in me from the
intercept inflation is good for you
over milk prices inflation is bad for
the one percent but helps out almost
everyone else that is
this is a funded shill controlled
opposition garbage media outlet lying to
people
let me just explain to all of you
inflation does nothing to the one
percent in fact
it helps them
one thing he points out in this article
that is true is that debt becomes worth
less as the dollar becomes worth less if
i owe someone 10 but then 10 can't buy
you anything anymore i basically don't
owe somebody any money right and he
argues that's good for poor people
because poor people hold all the debt
the problem is they still have the debt
now they can't afford to buy food either
so maybe they'll get lucky and
eventually their wages will go up and
then they can pay off their debt but let
me make one thing clear if you got 50
000 in debt and that debt gets devalued
because of inflation and you make 15
bucks an hour your 15 bucks an hour is
devalued because of inflation too and
you still can't pay after that and now
you can't buy food but a rich person can
take their money as soon as they get it
invested in stocks and assets which will
go up in value during inflation and
they'll say has no effect on me and i
tell you this rich people that go to the
store they don't know or care about the
price of milk the intercept and these
far left establishment crackpots are
manipulating poor people so they can
keep their crackpot biden in power and
this one pisses me off yeah because it
actually hurts people
tremendously it hurts the weakest it
hurts the poorest people in our society
and it takes advantage of them in such
an unfair freaking way where the federal
reserve is literally printing money
giving it to their friends in wall
street and everyone else is finding it
harder and harder to make ends meet and
why is that well well it's not because
of a political party it's because of the
financial system being literally a ponzi
scheme that everyone's going through and
this is not just the internship this has
been a coordinated effort through a lot
of corporate media organizations that
have been repeating the same lines
inflation's great cnn had a similar
headline cnn just had don lemon on
singing the praises of the president of
the united states saying can you believe
it so ah
five cents less for gas absolutely
insane rhetoric look at this celebration
victory in poor people becoming poorer
and the rich people becoming more
powerful than they ever have been
through the largest transfer of wealth
and recorded human history that we're
going through right now and it's
sickening to see happen right in front
of our eyes and then the corporate media
lie to the people saying it's not even
happening you're you're you're better
off no you're not this is no dirty dirty
game this makes me this is this is this
is this makes me angrier than i've been
for a lot of issues you know uh granted
i'm not nearly as mad as when the fbi
raided james o'keefe that was clearly
infuriating for me but to see all of
these massive multinational billion
billion-dollar corporations trying to
convince poor people that they are
gutting your savings your life your
ability to buy food everything you work
for for your family for your kids trying
to build a better life they are
stripping that away they are gutting you
you are being screwed over by the elites
and then what do they do they have the
intercept progressives and cnn tell you
it's a good thing it's happening these
poor people who get stuck in this and
believe this trash that's what i want i
don't want any power over any of you i
don't want any money from you i want you
to know that you have agency that you
should keep the money you earn that you
have a right to control your labor and
that these big companies these media
companies are lying to you so that the
amazons the walmarts these billion
dollars these billionaires are stripping
away your value while their cronies in
the federal reserve and the government
are printing away money and screwing
every one of us and you know who says
this steve bannon says this they call
him far right we have more in common
with left populists than we do at the
establishment the problem is people
watch too much cnn and believe this crap
if you are look if you are on on the
left if you're progressive or you know
someone who is please explain to them
that cnn is a trash rag that is lying
about everything
we're being we're being ripped off by
the entirety of the establishment well
and then what they do too is then the
federal government wants to give
everybody a lot of money right they want
to not only not only their jacking up
their prices and everything they want to
divide americans from their basic
ability to earn a living on their own so
they want to feed everybody money
they want to feed everybody all of these
services so that then americans are just
entirely reliant on the federal
government and don't have the ability to
uh you know earn their own bread take
care of their own families
and then we're going to be then we're
afraid to speak up why would we how
could we possibly speak up against
something that's so big and has so much
control over our lives at that point
they control you know they control
health care they control our income they
control our families and that's what all
of these programs are about that's what
these vast social engineering programs
are about where it's like let's give
everybody some free money it's not free
money it's control money it's money to
to take your liberty away from you you
guys sound like crazy conspiracy
theorists i believe uh jim cramer of
cnbc who just said that
today we have the strongest economy
perhaps
that i've ever seen so yes that's
literally what he said today i don't
know if you guys saw but the democrats
were tweeting about all of the jobs that
joe biden has created and i really hope
that all the rest of you guys saw this
chart that they put out showing the gas
prices are coming down well if you look
closely it's zoomed in so tight to the
cents on the dollar it goes from like
338 to 336 and they're like oh my gosh
the gas prices are coming down and it's
like you guys are joking right yes
seriously joe biden is not creating jobs
he's allowing people to go back to work
because i i'd like right i'd like you
all to see this gentleman yes a generous
god
yeah take a look at this
this is the democrats on twitter welcome
to the biden boom
and it says jobs created in the first 10
months of presidency
uh under uh under the underbide and the
economy has outperformed the past four
republican presidents job growth numbers
the funny thing about this is
they they're
it's just if you fall for this stuff
first it would be important to compare
biden to obama oh that would make obama
look bad
and uh and clinton no it's just the
republicans
they don't mention that the job growth
under biden is actually stagnant and
what happened was there was a major
collapse when democrat governors locked
down their states and then it bounced
back only a certain amount and has
struggled to recover since then but of
course if you take away six million jobs
and then snap your fingers and say you
can work again and you get 5.8 million
jobs then all of a sudden they're like
look how many jobs you made
these people are evil man i don't like
mitch mcconnell i don't like lindsey
graham i don't like kevin mccarthy i
don't like the established republicans
their whole plan is obstruction and do
nothing and you elect these people again
and they will do nothing we need to
primary them i don't i and look this is
why i cheered when aoc beat beat crowley
in new york because screw the
establishment democrats i'll take
whatever i can get the problem i think
aoc is still just another establishment
democrat but she's wearing a bernie mask
that being said primary all of them i
donated to a progressive leftist who was
trying to primary nancy pelosi because i
would rather someone be in office saying
i have bad policy ideas but i recognize
these huge lists of problems and be like
i can agree with that and we can work we
can work on something but when you have
the biden administration the
establishment democrats the hillary
clintons i came we saw he died and their
whole plan as well if we blow more kids
in a foreign country maybe that'll be
good for the economy then we'll claim to
have some kind of win and they gaffe
with afghanistan we have a real
opportunity to end that war they just
burn it to the ground they destroy that
i would rather have some some crackpot
lefty who's like i just want americans
to have healthcare and then i can be
like that's a bad plan for healthcare
but at least we agree we're not going to
spend our money on blowing up kids
well and it's so interesting too that
now they're laying the groundwork for
having like a whole ukraine thing it's
like they can't exist without having
some war to go fight but they're not
going to go against china china's their
business partner no and we saw that
already you know we should have been
standing up for hong kong and we
obviously we should have been standing
up for hong kong we just let them get
totally destroyed that was a that was a
relatively free place you know and we
just let them we just let those
protesters be imprisoned
uh we let the the pro-democracy movement
die
we and we did that because we're just
shilling for china it's so stupid like
these activists were out there with
their lives fighting for democracy in
hong kong fighting for free speech you
know working on that so hard and we just
let them down and in letting down hong
kong i do feel like we let down this
democracy project and now you hear the
administration sake you know coming out
there talking about the importance of
democracy globally and it's just such an
obvious
garbage thing they don't believe it at
all they just don't even believe it if
they believed it we would have stood up
for hong kong yeah i remember being in
hong kong during the uprisings and the
protests there and they were absolutely
intense and there was a warning
i remember spray painted saying
uh you know this happened here but it's
going to happen everywhere soon and it's
only a matter of time but they said it
more eloquently i forgot the exact
phrasing of it but uh to your point tim
i definitely agree with you mandatory
term limits put new people in there let
them give a give a try kick them out
kick all the people out to prevent all
the corruption i don't know a lot of
crap i think term limits could possibly
result in shadow organizers
and so there's challenges there there's
already a lot of shadows it's true it's
true but why should we tell ron paul he
can't run anymore because we're upset
that nancy pelosi is running too you
know what i mean it's like one in a
million yeah you know i suppose it goes
either way right you term limits get rid
of the bad but they could also get rid
of the good the way i see it is that
they're all uh criminals some criminals
are better because they have more
experience so
let in the new criminals whenever you
have someone stealing money and then and
then using it for their own purposes i
have my own definitions of my own
understanding of it but
you either have expert criminals or you
have rookie criminals i rather deal with
rookie criminals that don't know what
they're doing that aren't intertwined
with the system as much as the people
who are definitely intertwined like
nancy pelosi i think it's crazy that uh
we're supposed to say dr jill biden but
we're not supposed to say dr rand paul
right right right right right she's
totally a fake doctor she's a fake
doctor we got to talk about one of the
most important people in the world my
friends this is from timcast.com court
rules julian assange can be extradited
overturning previous ruling the final
decision to extradite falls to uk home
security pretty patel
the report says england's high court
said wikileaks founder julian assange
could be extradited to the united states
to face espionage charges and i love how
when you watch the shill establishment
democrat media they're like oh he was
hacking and the case is solid in
mourning joe spewing word vomit about
complete bullish that's not true
here's the reality julian assange is one
of the most important journalists of
this or any generation he exposed
malfeasance for for for i mean his
entire career ranging from malfeasance
in sub-saharan african nations all the
way to the democratic uh national
committee
for this the establishment seeks to
destroy his life and they've locked him
up now for what over a decade how long
has it been
um his first arrest was 10 years ago i
believe 10 years no 11 years excuse me
11 years since his arrest in the united
kingdom
it is it is overt and in our faces what
the scumbags
who who believe they have moral
authority over you and who control these
systems do with people like julian
assange who has done nothing wrong he's
been accused of of completely bs charges
as far as i'm concerned but let's talk
about something very very important
julian assange exposes corruption
jeffrey epstein was engaged in some of
the most disgusting and psychotic
corruption and atrocities we've seen and
who gets to go free and sit where was he
at queen elizabeth's cottage he was yeah
oh wow
you know what's really funny is that
they say that there's a conspiracy about
creepy elitists and what they want to do
and all that stuff and it's really funny
when when the maxwell trial ends with
only a few witnesses in a few weeks
epstein gets away with what everything
he's doing for two decades and julian
assange who's like here's here's
evidence of malfeasance they're like
destroy his life and him it's obvious
yeah this is a huge huge injustice and
has major ramifications for not just
free the free press in the united states
but for the world julian assange is not
an american citizen for him to be ruled
to be extradited to the united states to
face charges because he embarrassed the
deep state because he embarrassed the
pentagon and the intelligence agencies
of this country by showing the country
what they were actually doing and not
falling for their lives it's just
absolutely insane julian assange
immediately participated
don't bump the camera don't bump the
camera
come on at home
somebody
hi guys
20 minutes what up sexy uh everyone's
probably like wait what's going on
jackpot you gotta see this guy's suit
what's happening he's wearing a nice
fine suit
we're talking about julian assange
i just
i heard that you were talking about
china
and i was sitting in washington dc and
i've said i've got to go
i've got to go and now i'm here now i'm
here good tell us about here i am so
hong kong when you were talking about
hong kong and and and thank you so much
for being here libby we we love libby do
we all love libya
it's been a minute it has been a minute
no when when we did not support
hong kong when we passed them over when
we said even going back into the 1990s
remember this was the original
sense of it right
they said if we turn hong kong over
then hong kong's capitalist and liberal
system will be passed on and these
ideals of freedom will be go we'll go
into china china will become democratic
the ccp will disintegrate it'll be
amazing and
uh gordon chang wrote his book the
collapse of the ccp and it's it's coming
it's gonna be so great
and you look at everything everything
that luke talks about everything that
tim talks about everyone talks about
yeah we did open up that
that pathway but it wasn't a one-way
street it turned out it was a two-way
street and so we tried to send freedom
in it didn't take but what did they send
our way communism communism
authoritarianism
and we didn't support and i just i had
to come in and say it i just i'm sorry i
just come and say it i've been sitting
outside all day actually oh really yes i
have yeah did you meet my son downstairs
no it's one last year i know but is he
downstairs no no i didn't see him at all
there was some guy running and screaming
about some chickens earlier i don't know
possibly am i should i be terrified
well i mean if you it depends how much
you like chickens
we're a fan of the chickens we are
fantastic we're talking about assange
and the way i don't know if you heard
this last part we're just talking about
sanchez yeah i saw that i said well i
thought that he might be extradited yeah
oh might okay
so the appeal was ruled on but there's
still one last uh decision i believe at
a secretarial level um on whether or not
he'll be brought back to the united
states for the crime of embarrassing the
regime
yeah pretty much yeah like that's that's
what it should be the democratic justice
of american goodness like this this
veneer this like illusion and then
what's really happening is the most
corrupt epstein like child trafficking
thing and it's this is our government is
it's that and so that's why they're
going well the only question you have to
ask about delane maxwell is why was it
that why is it the oldest prosecutor
that sdny assigned to that case is 37
years old the other person they add oh
you got the chart the other person they
add on is james comey's daughter right
then that's not an investigation that's
a cover-up they're sitting there these
are the worst this is the worst
prosecution i've seen you know that she
actually might get acquitted she
actually might get acquitted because
they're not introducing evidence of
specific crimes that she committed in
terms of sex trafficking look i set
through the manafort trial i remember
here are the documents here are the bank
records here are the transfers here are
the emails right i know what it looks
like look look at how here this is all
you have to do this is all you have to
say put take the two stories
look at how the government's going after
julian assange and look at how light
they are against elaine max
that's exactly what i was saying and not
only that but they have thousands of
photos thousands of video tapes should
have been entered into evidence 20 000.
yep i gotta pull up this meme um so i
initially discovered this thanks to
sheamus of freedom tunes because he made
a very hilarious video about left-wing
memes and he talked about this but there
was something i discovered that was
really funny so this woman this is abby
richards and um which she she's a miss
and disinformation researcher this is
fantastic so she has this tweet where
she said conspiracy theories are
everywhere and people don't understand
how harmful they are i made the
conspiracy chart over a year ago here's
the updated version and so it's actually
quite silly she says speculation line
clear here's one that says like grounded
in reality and it's like watergate mk
ultra then it says we have some
questions and iran contra is in there
and a lot of people are like we don't
have like we know that happened
that's a historical event it was an
actual government conspiracy here's
here's the thing
here's the best part though right i want
to show you this i remember ollie north
testifying so let me let me this is the
the old uh um the old version she made
last year i was gonna say do you have
the one from last year the one from last
year there's a reason she had the update
right right but let me just show you i
want to show you i wonder what that is
there are a few things well hold on let
me we'll go through all of it speaking
of china but let me show you let me show
you the most my favorite one is this
the the top of the pyramid it says world
ruled by supreme shadow elites once you
believe one you usually believe most get
help she calls all of these these
theories anti-semitic and i noticed one
funny one in there when i was reading
this and it says bill gates
microchipping and that is in the
detached from reality anti-semitic
section she had to change it because
apparently she discovered how to use
google and found
this story from the national post
bill gates funds birth control microchip
that lasts 16 years inside the body and
can be turned on or off with remote
control
that's not a conspiracy theory there was
one real there was another one that she
had last year this is the one from this
year right the cultural marxism is up
there yeah of course yeah yeah so the
one right now wait scroll but go back
into science denial this is the one from
last year zoom in right below where it
says 5g look what it says was a
conspiracy theory
made in lab i love that one funny how
that one had to get taken off this year
i wonder what could have happened could
have been soy boys
is not a conspiracy they're a fact
alien abductions is less of a conspiracy
theory thank you and hypogona it's
called
it's called hypogonadism they went after
tucker carlson for talking about this
the idea that with some people when they
can track covet 19 you can go to the
nih's website and see it's called
hypogonadism and it actually will lower
your testosterone the same way that
we've seen testosterone levels going
down since the 1970s
what is what is mattress firm like yeah
what is that so the mattress firm one i
know this one was that the reason that
it was the theory that there were that
there because it was trending onto this
is what i do i find out something is
trending on twitter i say oh this is
trending on twitter and this is what
people are saying and then people say
i'm promoting it right
right so the mattress firm thing was
people said why are there so many
mattress firms how could there possibly
be so many people out there buying a
product that you really only buy once or
twice every you know like in your
lifetime right that you buy a mattress
and so they were i mean think of it how
many times do you buy mattresses you
know what i mean yeah and
um and so the idea is the idea right so
the idea was that it was actually a
money laundering operation and then
people were trying to like find out if
there were some issues going on because
they were going around wait
yeah i think okay so i think yeah you
know so remember they were talking about
the wayfarer thing or the overstock.com
thing and they're like well this yeah no
that was separate that was different
from yes you guys could think you guys
ready yeah so in the old conspiracy
chart at the at the very top you see
deep state is up there right and that
one's silly because that just refers to
the the establishment you know
intelligence bureau which isn't even i
mean it's not a conspiracy it's
literally just a function they call it
the administrative state but just to the
right yeah i used to work there is
celebs moisturize with children's
foreskin
i would like to pull up people i would
like to pull up the guardian from 2018.
i tried the foreskin facial treatment so
you don't have to yeah wow
and he literally says in the guardian
they do this he doesn't look good he
looks worse i think he gets much worse
well there's celebrities bragging about
this uh on national television there was
a number of them saying this on record
yeah nobody there was also there were
all of the silicon valley executives who
were getting the blood of younger people
pumped into that that's true that's been
that's that was true too yeah yeah but
for a while they said it was a
conspiracy it was like it works but the
other thing about about the the
mattresses real quick before no no it
literally works you know yeah it is
proven that um doing a transfusion of
younger blood helps regenerate and heal
your body is it like a stem cell thing
is that the idea i think it's just
because there's something in the blood i
forgot what it's called that do you know
what it's called i don't know oxygen no
no there's like there's like when you
get older your body produces less of
some particular like enzyme or something
no no no
that's the plasma right there's
something else i forgot you have to spin
the blood a little bit and get the right
particles and then um people use it for
like dental surgeries as well yeah
younger people have more of it so they
transfuse younger blood into an older
person it helps regenerate organs and
stuff like that right now but real quick
before we forget the other thing about
the mattresses is that if you want to
upgrade your mattress you can simply go
to my phone oh my god
i get the mattress topper you don't have
to support the money laundering
operation of mattress firm you use promo
code post so the two inch or the three
inch topper particularly we like the
bigger one we've got the foam it's
amazing i just want to say i appreciate
how unapologetic you are about it i
appreciate the fact that you are so no
one thing that libby does not everybody
knows this she likes to pass on the
bible stories to her children yes she's
a child your child right
one of the best ways to do that is with
the my pillow
bible story pillow
you pass the pillow cases you pass it's
noah's ark the nativity scene every
single night jack jack says good good
night joseph good night mary good night
baby jesus and good night sheep
available lindell should have you do a
commercial he really should yeah but his
commercials are next level though his
commercials are next level i could never
get we got to go to super chats but i'm
going to read one from the bottom real
quick because rayne20j says jack just
strolls in
suit
no i'm sorry he says jack just strolls
in suit on to start schooling everyone
on china
surprise post i just got my worthless
ideas shirt from luke gonna wear it to
christmas
and then he says a word in polish i
can't read oh boy jikuji gingkoi
thank you thank you luke welcome to the
uh luke welcome to the ish show oh so
nice all right let's read some super
chats
um the first super chat i can't read
your name because of the way youtube
formats this unfortunately but they say
police are now starting to hunt down
antifa cells justice may be coming back
let us pray
yeah we talked about that earlier you
saw that uh in california they went out
in san diego yeah i mean look this is
something that barr had said he was
going to do through the joint terrorism
task forces so finally we're seeing
little bits and pieces of fruition
because and when i've worked on the
antifa problem set i always find that
there's there's always some guy right
like back in the back of the office he's
usually working on the gang desk or
something and he's just got the
spreadsheet full of like every antifa
all up and down the east coast the
philadelphia cell the washington dc cell
the new york cell they all know they all
know and in fact you remember that
that time where you know i got into it
in in dc and there's like that photo of
us so after that after we you know i got
out um the police picked me up i was in
the back of the of the van and you know
starting to kind of explain what
happened and there's this dude just
literally sitting all the way in bed
he's like oh no you are jack
like yeah i know who that was yeah we've
been tracking you guys all week like so
are you are you and they don't do
anything you're doing anything about it
well it's their hands are all tied their
hands are complete but there's always
some guy who knows yeah they have all
the data they have all the surveillance
they know everything that's going on
they have secret surveillance drones
that are literally at almost every
single protest kyle rittenhouse proved
it yeah and i approved that story by
league 14 months they kept this the fbi
had and you believe really leave us to
mean we want us to believe that they
only had a minute 39 no luke is exactly
right about that they have all the
databases
all the anti-pharmaceuticals i was
shocked when you called me to like tell
me about that right right yeah before
yeah oh my god that was crazy to see
that i was like i've got a thing
love a thing i love when you call me
with a thing chris stark says the
national blm group is a democratic super
pac not only did those at the top line
their pockets but also they are the
reason why the democrats were able to
amass so much campaign finances yeah it
doesn't get they get like a billion
dollars was that true or is that like i
think that
that was a few years ago they had raised
a total of wasn't it like how much well
there was a there were a few issues too
because there were people who were just
kind of like opening up you know c3s and
super pacs and saying hey we're blm of
st louis we're a blm of arkansas where
and then the local companies would say
oh of course we're giving to blm but
it's literally just some guy who filed a
paperwork and there were i think there
was a guy wasn't there maybe it was
atlanta and it turned out that he he was
saying he was blm that's exactly that's
what i was thinking about yeah he wasn't
he wasn't affiliated with anybody no he
was just a guy who opened up he was like
hey i'm gonna be blm now yeah and he had
like a facebook page and it looked you
know and if you didn't know any better
it's oh yeah wait when was the first
this was this is 2012 during the during
the day you're not talking about the guy
who had black lives matter first are you
no there was a guy who had his own black
lives matter organization before the
official formation wow
and they sued him like pre ferguson i'm
pretty sure like he said that when black
ops matter was like starting up he
formed an organization to do exactly
what black minds made was doing but
there was no big centralized
organization and so then they went after
him and all of the leftist press started
claiming he was fake when he was he was
the real guy he was a regular activist
who was raising money and it just so
happened that black lives matter became
huge and they donated to him well i
think he got like 350k in total
throughout his few years operating it it
became huge but it's still not like a
very organized organization right i mean
you even heard patrice cullers talking
about
black lives matter saying that it's
leaderless you know that it doesn't have
any leader that you could take one
leader out and a new leader would emerge
it's a hydra you know it doesn't have so
it has the people who are like
prospecting zombie horde sure
hydro
black lives matter credit and i don't
think i heard you guys say this earlier
that they came out this week and they
said that no matter what happens in that
courtroom in chicago we believe
justice
and they said even though he's been
convicted and found guilty of lying to
the police we still believe justice take
the loss people seriously you know
i guess the cop who arrested him said
that if he had apologized they'd let him
go wow i believe it really but he he
stood firm he stood his ground that he
was attacked by homophobic and he white
supremacist trump supporters who were
actually the crazy thing too is on a tv
show he probably wouldn't have been
facing jail time until he got up and
perjured himself for two full days
amazing in front of the jury
with the judge it's like
uh you know the piece of legal advice
and will chamberlain mention he's like
yeah don't do that
i would have absolutely 100 percent
forgiven and respected justice millett
if he apologized and owned up to it if
he was 100 100 this was ill-thought-out
when joey says perhaps not the thing to
do let's hear it let's hear it do you
remember joey salads yeah
joey uh uh
he he took a car brought it to like this
apartment building uh yeah he put a
bunch of trump stickers and stuff in it
and then he's like let's see what
happens and then he hired black people
to smash it up right and they said
you're racist you staged this as a hoax
all this stuff he got caught but wasn't
it supposed to see he wanted to see what
people's reaction to seeing that would
be or was it one of those videos
he made a video where
you believed the guy who filmed it
waited for him to publish it where you
believed that by parking a car with
trump stuff in it a bunch of young black
men would destroy it just smashed the
car up and it was fake the guys he hired
the guys it was staged and it was making
people believe that there was this like
racist attack and then he got called out
and then everyone started slamming him
and he decided to turn around own up to
it apologize he flat out said in an
interview with me i was caught up in the
money and the clicks i didn't i didn't
understand how far gone i had become
when i was chasing after this stuff and
i was like dude
if you're going to come out and own that
like we want to welcome you back to the
light and say just please don't do it
again and now what does he do he does
viral clips where it's him and his
girlfriend doing pranks and it's
wholesome and family friendly for the
most part jesse smellette could have
done the same thing and i would have
said the exact same thing i don't want
jesse turning towards the darkness i
want to come back to the light i want
him to be a figure to inspire positivity
but he doubles down he purges himself
and now he's going to go to jail for it
well and forgiveness is such a beautiful
thing and it's something that they you
know the contemporary left has no room
for an admission of guilt on the left is
you know uh
a reason to believe further in your
guilt and culpability there's no way out
of it you know and that's not that's one
thing that i think christianity offers
that we miss so much in contemporary
society is that you can say
i'm sorry
and you know then the person who you
offended in some way can say hey no
worries we're good now in christianity
man being flawed man having a sinful
nature that this is built in right it's
like oh i committed the same yeah we
know
we all do yeah that's part of it
yeah you can never be perfect and that's
but in that's
you know
whatever you want to call modern
communism that we have today there isn't
so they've created it is a religion but
it's so interesting but it has no
atonement right and it's modern
communism without um without class which
is so weird it's a it's it's a communism
that upholds the powerful elite
structure
well that is it and historically
speaking you know but like yeah but like
in the text that's not what you would
anticipate and it just completely
destroys the working class let's raise
like the contemporary
left has no respect for a working person
all right let's read some more here we
got tim
crespi he says tim got pulled over going
through a parking lot to get to another
road so did 10 other people by four
different cops
starting to align with malice
you know i i i don't think getting
pulled over for jumping a parking lot is
like grounds to be like all cops are
like so starting to align with mouse is
a good way to frame it beginning of the
month end of the month but like right
yeah but that's quotes that's quotas man
michael mouse's position is there is no
law so you know egregious that a cop is
so heinous that a cop is right is not
willing to enforce it up into uh up and
including executing children
if you're upset that a cop pulled you
over because you jumped a parking lot
you're a bit far away from mike where
michael is but i do think it's important
to point out that it is the grains of
sand of cops being like there's no
humanity here it's quite literally i
know it was a nothing it was it was a
turn i'm going to screw you over anyway
like these are the kind of things that
build up for people and make them
finally snap do people know what the
quotas are you know what i'm talking
about
quotas like at the end of the month the
cops like i'm supposed to get a thousand
tickets this month i only have seven
hundred let's kick it yeah it's not
gonna be that much oh really be very
careful about the speed limit towards
the end of the month but then at the
start of the next month you're good
dude i gotta i gotta read one super chat
quotas are insane megan murdoch says tim
my birthday is tomorrow pretty please
wish me happy birthday
happy birthday megan murdock yes
is that happy birthday in mandarin it is
we had um uh jan uh yakelik the other
day yeah great yeah good friend of mine
yeah so so you know luke and him are
speaking polish and then someone super
chatted how are you collecting so many
polls somebody mentioned you but then
luke was like he doesn't speak polish
uh uh
says vote for your local sheriff the uh
the only elected law enforcement office
definitely yes local 100
flash arc says tim please read counter
woke craft to understand how to defeat
the woke zombies also read this aloud
what's counter well crap i'm not
familiar i don't know no familiar sounds
interesting is it like communists are
bad they are though
yeah all right let's see i agree
i agree ditto
martin edgar says tim you called it the
authority used the terror organizations
of antifa and blm and are now going
after them since they have no use for
them now perhaps in three years they
will cuddle up to them again
yeah i think what we were saying was
that with the midterms coming up with
the economy being so bad i think this
the democrats are all right they're a
liability
and i actually had heard in within the
white house that kamala was this was
something she was saying that you know
we should actually
go after some of the antifa groups
because then that will actually kind of
balance it out with what they're doing
with the january 6 people um and so
it'll look like we're actually going
after both sides
and but then it also historically
speaking this was what china did when
they dealt with the red guards they had
to clean it up and eventually they said
look they just sent the military and
they said you got to get rid of these
guys and kick them all out to the
countryside because they were nuts
somebody super chatted saying the one
thing that uh this is rick russell one
thing that always bugged me is your your
katana and boom blaster behind you isn't
square it's like 40 degree 50 40 50.
mouth love from canada um
that's what you were looking at you're
right that's because tim's shoulders are
are a little bit slightly
so so when he has to grab them quickly
that's that's exactly where they are
i can i can i think it's because i put
the the screw in the wrong spot and i
could easily fix it
not the screw i put the i mounted it on
the wrong side which again because your
arms are not equal my arms are slightly
uneven slightly uneven yeah i like your
telecaster
oh yeah the brett mason
what are the what are the pickups on
that um i couldn't tell you okay
seymour duncan the uh uh yeah i couldn't
tell you i was told if you leave your
picture but in the strings like that it
ends up
messing up the pickup probably yeah
but it messes up something the middle
one is an active pickup it's got a
switch you can turn on and play all
three at the same time it sounds really
full it's amazing maybe it's got a b
bender on it so you can like put the
strap and then like bend the neck and
bring your room it's cool very chris
chrome awesome guitar very cursed
cornell all right let's see what we got
here we got to forest i live walking
distance from that from that protest and
can only be grateful that it's been
relatively tame compared to the rest of
the country on another note our local
gun stores have been doing well lately
oh yeah yeah man i got some info on
counter woke craft it's a field manual
for combating the woke in the university
and beyond by
charles pincourt and james lindsay oh
james lindsay yeah
you guys have you seen that clip from
what are the sex in the city going
around no i've seen it going around but
i haven't watched it yet i've been
watching it that show so much is so
boring and stupid but i wasn't sure was
this a parody of really sex in the city
or this what sex
sex in the city ruined millennial women
yes
so child so childless millennial women
are going to be a huge problem going
forward
they're going to be miserable
they're just going to be miserable and
right but the issue is that they're
going to be getting more power
yeah and they're going to vote and
they're going to vote and they're going
to be lawyers and they're going to be in
the doj and they're going to be judges
i'm just saying when they're in their
70s they're all going to vote for state
you know like state funded
like elderly care of some sort like
they're what i mean to say is instead of
relying on family yeah and private
individual support they're gonna their
their only choice is going to have to be
some kind of more socialist or communist
which is exactly what was marketed to
them remember the obama address for
julia 100 percent you know
yeah yeah and then biden had one too
yeah it was like i don't know her
son yeah yeah
what's nice is that
i think
women are being sold no relationship
right your primary relationship is with
the federal government right yeah so i
think zoomers are starting it's like
zoomer um females and and males like in
general are looking at this and saying
looking at millennials and saying okay
this is generally a failed generation um
you you made really bad decisions some a
lot of which was you know due to
external factors there was a lot of
crazy stuff that millennials went
through in their formative years and
that's true but at the same time we're
going to learn from these mistakes and
we're going to make corrections very
quickly a lot of them are also going to
be very pissed off when they find find
out how scammed they were by everything
yes so there's also a big pushback
against it as well they're going to find
out
i want to read it you know i hope they
do find out fast and i hope that it's
not too late for them to you know have
families and don't be like us
yeah and i want to say points for
self-awareness on the topic of sex in
the city this one of the stars came out
and said i really regret living the
feminist life i'm really sorry that i
don't have a family i'm sad that i don't
have kids i was like oh which do you
remember which one that was i don't
think it was kim catrell and didn't they
write her out or something probably oh
no way
i think they did i think she's not in
this one that's all i know about sexism
all i know is i was watched i was like
looking for something to watch one time
and i was like talking to my brother i
was like oh you know i'll watch sex in
the city i never really watched that
show and he was like liz you're gonna
hate this show it
and i was like well i'll give it a try
everybody likes it i put it on i watched
like half an episode i called my brother
i was like you're right you're right i
hate this so much i hate it so much
everything about this is pure hell it
sucks yes and it's it's uh it's not it
has nothing no relevance to the new york
city that i know remember
evil cannot create evil can only corrupt
i want to okay i'm going to read
something that's going to be offensive
to feminists because i often do
carl benjamin posted this on instagram
it's getting better it's a reddit post
where they where it's titled
attractiveness over 30. and it says hi
32 female have started feeling insecure
over the past couple of years as i see
more and more of my male acquaintances
in their late 30s and over dating women
in their early to mid 20s
i am by no means unattractive quite the
opposite but seem to have trouble
finding men interested in
age-appropriate relationships what is
going on can someone just what is going
on can someone just please reassure me
that there are men in their thirties out
there interested in women in their
thirties
uh maybe but this is not a new
phenomenon girl
libby take it off take it away this is
what happens my grandfather when he was
like in his 70s was dating a woman in
her 40s
come on like this is what happens men
can date anyone they want at any point
in their lives and the older they get
the more access to the dating pool that
they have
and women like when you fall in love
with somebody and you're in your 20s and
you think to yourself you know i really
want to pursue something else i don't
really have time for love in my life
right now i want to upgrade have the
love take the love when love comes to
you in life
accept it with an open heart and move
forward
you know grow together grow together
create a family create a life together
yes young men can't compete an 18 year
old guy struggles to compete against a
30 year old guy yes he has no job he
doesn't know what he's doing he can
barely grow a beard like come on unless
you're unless you're kyle rittenhouse
okay he's going to be fine yeah he'll be
good there are some young people who
reach you know status that you know
faster than others but an 18 year old
man and an 18 year old woman that 18
year old woman is going to have it's
going to be a breeze she pops open
bumble or twitter or okcupid and she has
max messages and she can go through the
pick of the litter
18 year old guy is going to get nothing
right but those those those
apps are also creating are also part of
the problem absolutely because they're
they are expanding the dating pool far
beyond what it ever was was historically
speaking and so you're going to have 80
percent of the women going for the top
five percent of the men like it was back
when uh when we were tribal and nomadic
right but the pool was still but the
pool was small right right right but
this thing though
where people say to themselves like oh
you know this is my high school
boyfriend or this is my college
boyfriend or whatever and this isn't the
right time for me now i need to go to
graduate school before i can embark on
you know before i can accept love in my
life that's the stupid idea
you know when you fall in love like
accept it go with that well hold on we
have a super chat from john cordisco he
says love love libby sadly i'm too old
for her
my guess is he has no idea how old i am
nice uh we we've done a bunch of
segments we have we've had a few guests
where we've talked about this phenomenon
there was one story from i think the new
york post covered it said women in their
30s are struggling to find men who make
the same amount they do and it's and
it's and the funny thing is
it's really simple and i'm not i don't
say this to be offensive but boy does
this really trigger the left a guy who's
35 who's making 80 000 a year
can find a woman who's 24 and he's going
to be like hey i make 80 thousand a year
you want to go to the movies or go take
and she's like wow okay he's got the
ability to
like have fun and a guy the same age as
her is probably broken in college
then a woman who's 35 he's going to be
like but i can have any woman you know
all these younger women why would i you
know go out with you especially like
you're busy working all the time right
you're pursuing your career have fun
with that yeah yeah and like here's
someone who's young in college and not
working and wants to have fun right this
was the lie of sex in the city this is
what was pushed this was said that you
that you have to sacrifice one for the
other and you don't true you don't and
the other thing too i mean you can have
a career you can have love you can do
all like do them together team up team
up yes you know and make this happen
literally it's the plot of every
hallmark movie you know what there's a
reason that they keep making hallmark
movies right and those movies are
awesome and they're all profitable and
they're all profitable we watch them i
saw a reddit too there was this guy and
he was like uh ladies would you date a
garbage man of course because i just got
an offer to be a garbage man heck yeah
and it's a lot of money but i hesitate
what i'm pointing at the podcast arm the
podcast arm
in this campaign office where i worked
in uh in pennsylvania years ago
and um he
like really got freaked out with him as
well so i had a little glass box and i
just used to collect them and then i
would and then i would hide it in
different places in the office and then
i would tell them it'd be like hey can
you you know grab some staples and stuff
that he would open up
be gentle with him if you hit him too
hard they release a stinky thinking yeah
i would put it like in his in his desk
drawer libby so what happened would the
women date the garbage man oh a bunch of
women were basically like a swoon of
course yes yeah of a job yeah so he's a
good job and he with benefits and he
pulls down nearly 86 figures all right
yeah that sounds amazing and he has to
get up early yeah right and then you
know and he also he was like this job
will give me weekends off i don't have
that hat yeah weekend's off yeah you
know and he eventually concluded the
post with i'll just tell people that i'm
a delivery driver perfect i'm really and
he has a great immune system yeah
yeah excellent but there's no like this
sort of goes there's no shame in honest
work yeah i if i was a garbage man i'd
be like oh i'm a garbage man yeah me too
and you know i feel very grateful for
the ability to earn a living
to work i'm so happy for that you know
yeah and it makes me sad that these
women have been sold the lie that they
can't have both well you know we could
actually we could actually interview
there's there's someone else who's here
that we could interview that could
actually ask about this situation
someone i personally know who got
married in her twenties had her first
son at 22. went on to an incredibly
successful career come on come on
come on
check yourself a lady here a very lovely
lady ladies and gentlemen it is my mom
oh snap my mom laurie hello
strike a note with me because yeah just
to come down a little bit yeah married
fairly young had jack when i was 23.
i had my associate's degree and i worked
at a
pharmaceutical company
microbiologist got a job
and i went and i got my bachelor's and
my master's
i had two children worked i just retired
for 40 years congratulations okay it
sounds like you had it all yeah it's
true
turned out i just turned 60 but i have
two little grandchildren and i feel
young enough that i can run around and
chase them around which i just did
that's
[Laughter]
wait until the best time to have
children it's never going to happen
because there is no best time there is
no best time that's something i wish i
have one son
if i'd known that there was no best time
i might have two
would you have girl talk yes do it right
check it out
i mean i wish i could have done
part-time i did work full-time but we
had a lot of support you know yeah was
it the support was in the community uh
family that's nice yeah it's perfect
yeah yeah i really think that women have
just been sold such a lie that they they
either have to choose one or the other
and i think it's wrong i think that if
you find someone that you love you have
to find a way to make it work and if
that means adjusting your work schedule
you need to make it happen because
that's way more important than a job and
you know the thing too is like you know
it doesn't always work out but you still
have to go for it yeah you can you can't
say when love comes into your life you
can't just say no to it yeah and they've
been told they have to right because
something else is more important and
self-fulfillment through career
you know that can be a thing or whatever
but it's never going to be
as fulfilling
you know as
having a team as teaming up as having a
family you know being a mom is literally
the best thing that i ever did and it's
my favorite thing ever you know
everything i do is like in service
that's pretty awesome you know yeah for
being a mom to jack of course
but everything i do is like you know
that's that's the most important thing
right you know it's like raising my son
to be a good man yeah when you you got
out of hi i didn't get your name what is
your favorite lori
uh when you so you like you go to high
school and then get married and have
kids uh i got an associate's degree
right out of high school like vet tech
and i got a job
did you meet like the father of your
children while you were in school
[Laughter]
so what did you like know him in high
school yes oh okay very cool yes he's
older than i said seven years older oh
nice so at that time that was literally
what we were just saying my scandal yeah
yeah it is that's scandalous
yeah
that's literally what tim was just
saying though that's that actually
proves the point that and that you met
what 1977 give or take yeah same your
star wars came out um
that but that proves the point that
dad to you was more attractive than
someone who was your own age for a
variety of reasons right therefore more
competitive and a more compatible
partner yeah
that's true like this this is actually
just a traditional thing so sorry you
know
read it lady
i'm not sure where we got the idea that
we have to be the same age as each other
i find that one partner having a little
more life experience is a huge advantage
communism that's a big deal oh communism
made us up well so the the people who
want to create this uh they want to
destroy traditional culture and create
this flat blank slate society needs to
eliminate gender differences which are
um to i mean
there are immutable and like on average
i should say
gender differences right they exist and
hormones play a huge role it's
fascinating to me that they can quite
literally say like oh we're going to
have an athlete perform in the olympics
as a trans athlete as long as their
testosterone is below a certain
threshold
so you're quite literally saying that
men who produce more testosterone than
women are affected by that and thus
there's serious biological differences
between males and females there there's
never i said this before you know they
pulled that right yeah yeah yeah but
there this one i'll tell you what really
triggers really triggered the feminist
when i said there will never be
equality between men and women there
could be political equality like you
can't discriminate on the base equality
under the law right for sure but the
idea i'll put it very very simply
if there's a man and a woman and they
both want to get a career and then have
kids the woman will always have to be
the one who creates that child which
puts them out of work for even a short
amount of time that disadvantages them
i'm not saying it means they can't
achieve i'm saying yeah i don't think
that's a disadvantage i don't think
having the ability to create and carry
life is a disadvantage i think it's an
extra it's an additional responsibility
women do have an outsized responsibility
for the furtherance of you know humanity
itself uh but is that a disadvantage
well it's just not like in the workplace
right is that a gift
of absence you know sure that sort of
thing but if you have to take even a
week off of work that a man doesn't then
that man has an extra week to do the
work right but i also agree that one of
the biggest problems is looking at that
as as being a disadvantage the idea that
a woman gets to have a woman women get
to have children yes it's like oh that's
so i'm so sorry that's going to hurt
your careers prospects instead of being
like talking about that's amazing
congratulations i i feel very strongly
about this as well because i feel like
we tell women in society that we say you
know and this goes back to abortion as
well we say that being a mother is not
something that's valuable that being a
mother detracts from your fulfillment as
a human being you know and we tell
people you know oh you're poor
uh you don't have a lot of prospects
being a mother is not for you you should
abort this child why aren't we saying
instead like motherhood is kind of the
greatest thing ever
and every woman can be qualified to be a
mother you know suck it up
woman up as they say you know and like
like do it yeah do it and and respect
yourself and respect your ability to
give life if if you have the gift and
can do that you know not every woman can
do that
um and that's a tragedy for a lot of
women but
you know you can do this you can be a
mother if you're 17 and you're pregnant
you can be a mother you can do this you
know
kaylian uh kailyn shaw indie game says
is this a pass or fail of the bechdel
test
this right now fun episode everyone the
bechdel test is the stupidest it's
garbage
you know because they're talking
standard what is it right
the bechdel test is this thing where the
idea is
in scripts and in entertainment you have
to have sections of the uh of the script
where women are talking together but
they're not talking about men
right and if they're not then it doesn't
pass the like feminism test
but i don't know about y'all but like
when i get together with my girlfriends
we talk about men a lot like this is a
big part of the conversation we talk
about other stuff we talk about work we
talk about our kids we talk about you
know whatever stupid thing is going on
in the world but mostly we talk about we
talk about men we talk about like oh who
are you dating yes because what are you
doing you know what happened with that
guy did he call you back like you know
this is what we talk about talking about
my ex sucks too like that's what you
talk about yeah it's interesting to talk
about someone who's so different from
you and it's like well what are they
doing what are they up to we talk about
relationships right you know that's a
huge that's a huge part of my life
gossipers uh no we don't no it's not
gossiping
i remember after or i guess when she was
pregnant with our first son was
you know it's you know
men can do some pretty incredible things
you know
throughout history men have done
incredible things but
women can create life it's pretty
amazing it's actually a miracle from god
that women have the ability to do this
and i think men innately know that you
know we can create you know we could
create art or a civilization or build a
city or architect whatever we can do
that too but and
no my point is but but men can never do
that ever
and it's not going to be possible and so
well they got some uh it's
transplant
whoopi comes out and she's talking about
this the roe v wade uh ruling and she
says
you men shouldn't have uh any say in
this because you don't have any eggs and
if you don't have any eggs you cannot be
children i say whoopi you need to calm
it down with the transphobia yes
that's right that's right you know i've
i had i've had male friends who have
been in relationships where the woman
has had an abortion and hasn't told them
and they have been like dude
do i am i is it okay if i grieve for
this or is that anti-feminist and i was
like you can grieve the loss of the
child that you would have wanted
if you had known about it yes you can
grieve that you know you can just
imagine a scenario where there's like 10
dudes you know on an island and humanity
gets like wiped out in a nuclear war
they're just sitting there they all look
around and be like
in 40 years humans won't exist you can
do the same thing with 10 women staying
on an island after the apocalypse say i
look around and say hmm well we're due
in 40 years humans won't exist you get
at least one woman at least one man that
can be like all right let's try and make
this work there has to be men and women
are required for building that
civilization but without women there's
no babies no i mean without men there's
also no babies i mean yeah well right
right right i mean like women make them
women women carry the baby you can have
ten women and one guy and your society
will will flourish
women are able to do art and build
civilizations but also have the basics
and this is why this is why men male
lives typically is particularly in the
west are are devalued in many cases
right men
uh we we are seen as expendable right
men are the ones who go and do build the
pipelines and they're out on oil rigs
they're doing uh fishing with fishing
boats actually it's one of the most
fatal that's a dangerous job careers
yeah occupation that there is and this
these are all male jobs there's you know
there's not a look
there weren't a lot of female coal
miners all i'm saying yes and uh i look
forward i'm really excited for feminists
getting these achievements um i know
recently that uh
daughters yeah well that was shot that
was struck down they removed that
language from the defense or whatever oh
yeah and so unfortunate loss for
feminists but i'm really excited for in
the netherlands they have more female
garbage persons okay and i actually
think that's fantastic it literally is
people should be doing whatever job they
want i'm really excited for women when
women start working on petroleum rigs
yes
high death rate unfortunately in that
line of work or good money
you know what are cool though on the
petroleum rigs are those those boats you
know those boats that like shoot out the
side yeah and they go
those are so cool
the issue that everybody knows is that
many of these feminists when they're
talking about equality they want to be
in corner office 50th floor
air-conditioned you know buildings they
don't want to be in sewers waiting
through human waste to try and make the
system you know yeah i don't want the
sewage flow yeah
either but i i i welcome all people of
all sizes and shapes and genders and
races to work in sewers and work as ceos
it just depends on what you're good at
with that being said i want to read one
more super chat and then we've gone a
little bit over but we're going to read
this one this is from shane kerwood he
says this turned out to be such a
wholesome episode evan love you guys and
thanks for doing what you all do it's so
important to get the truth out here uh
there's just a bunch of people have been
commenting since you know jack you came
in and with your with your lovely mother
it's been a really fantastic end of the
show for the week and i think we have a
very special segment we'll put together
right i believe talking about you know
marriage and all this stuff and getting
input from your mom which has been
fantastic yeah very cool i i was i'm
sitting here and i noticed the door
slowly opening and i'm like what is
happening who's coming
you know why because you weren't
checking twitter while we were doing
this oh why were you tweeting like
i saw it on there
should i crash irl i suggested that you
did did you see i was like come in i
didn't
respond
she invited you i did no it was i mean
look you know it's we're going into
christmas season here we're getting
towards the end of the year we're
thinking about that kind of stuff a lot
of these issues have been out there
lately
and you know i think it is good to show
that you know
we are family people and we are family
oriented and there is a goodness of that
it's not just you know
chattering about you know the news every
day that there is something more there's
something beyond and i think that's good
and i think that's something that
independent media like this
can show that you you would never see a
segment like this on cnn you know what i
mean right yeah it's just not just
that's just two people i mean we did get
to see brian selter in his underwear
that one time that was exciting good
gravy yeah
greatest nightmare you're bringing back
mike you're triggering my ptsd
but i was the opposite of
family-friendly wholesome and all that
stuff all right everybody uh go to
tipcast.com become a member it's friday
but we'll be back monday for sure you
can follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends you can
follow me at timcast uh libby you want
to shout anything out yeah i'm libby
evans on twitter and i'm at the post
millennial and you can help us out you
can help us fight antifa come on over
there and throw in a donation and read
what we've got to say
thepostmillennial.com
and my website is enough of
censorship.com one of the best things
you could do is not follow me on big
tech social media you could sign up on
my email list which is free available
for everyone where we try to keep you
informed enough of censorship.com thanks
for having me
guestballmediancrossline.net
and i'll catch you later great to see
you jack glad you guys popped in thank
you appreciate that uh support moms
support grandmoms you want to come see
us uh we'll be at america fest next week
in phoenix flying there on sunday coming
tomorrow are you coming
i will see you there
and uh for everybody else just uh you
know god bless and um
merry christmas i am so glad that jack
gate crashed us because i love talking
about this stuff especially with libby
because i really don't like feminism
very much either when i was 11 i was
like this seems like it's hurting women
more than helping them and ever since
then it's just been like yep i was right
yeah it kind of got all screwed around
yeah a little wild anyway you guys may
follow me on twitter at sourpatchlids
this has been a fantastic episode for
the season thanks so much jack for
popping in and lori this has been
wonderful and thanks for your insights
uh it was it was this was this was great
i love it it was an excellent friday
night it was just special just great
yeah and to everybody who's watching
we're gonna go relax and take the
weekend thanks for hanging out and we'll
see you all next time bye guys
you